the content creator yeah he's the fucking content creator
bro that guy was scary in Overwatch and scary in Apex that's
true yeah he's creating content by killing us yeah that's
the content
our content is our content is dying to Sully wait wait we
know where he's landing we can just rotate away from Sully
that's it or we just go into them and just and just feed
them the chat yeah just feed them kill points let's get oh
okay do you guys know later i don't even look at where we're
landing i i for team one oh wait somewhere we're landing
somewhere we're not thank you yuris i i believe in us even
more now
Solo mode, duo mode, trio mode.
All right, trio mode.
Wait, is it only Stormpoint for trios?
No, I'm pretty sure we have different...
There's no way it's only Stormpoint.
I think we played it once.
I'm pretty sure we're rotating maps, right guys?
Oh, we have World's Head.
We have World's Head.
There's like...
There's no way...
We are landing staging.
That is not bad.
Wouldn't call it the best...
Or the team's next to us.
We have something.
Where are the teams next to us?
We have one Tappi.
We have Tatsuki and Hesiko.
Two Japanese pros, pretty much.
Okay.
That's great to hear, man.
I feel so motivated.
One Tappi and Kohaku.
A pro and a predator.
And someone else.
We have 11.
Who's 11?
Yukio.
What the fuck?
Why are the...
Why are the scary people around us?
oh also the the zones are really fucked right now oh wait
wait what do you mean you you've been you've been playing
like a lot of customs right oh yeah no no yeah the one was
yeah i played with like the the fucking nessie cup with the
yeah no those those those zones are fucked yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's like yeah i had like gen on my team and like chill
like that and then it was like in the fucking open like the
end zones were so bad
so i haven't played this game in a while so i just i'm just
gonna be in the back just chilling yeah you're easier your
igl just if we if we die it's just poor igl right yeah yeah
it's not my fault yeah i'm used to it trust me i'm used to
it just poor igl that's it it's not because we're we're
washed as fuck it's no why would that be the case bro if i
didn't call that we wouldn't have been in that situation
that's right i i believe in this i i believe in us not being
last i'm gonna go in with like super low expectations as
long as we're not last that yeah exactly yeah yeah as long
as like you know we're not we don't like that i like that we
don't go we don't place some other poor team dies 20th place
and it's not us that's just fine yeah that's a that's a
fucking win for me that is a win for me you know exactly you
know what that's that let's make that our goal you know yeah
i just remembered like you know like when i saw like the the
landing spots announcements i was like okay what's your east
doing right now and i see you fucking playing Overwatch.
I was like, that seems right.
He's locked in.
He's like, I'm like, my GL and pro is super fucking locked
in.
Let's go.
Exactly.
I've heard it from the previous rank number one in Apex.
Just play Overwatch.
If you want to aim train.
That's true.
A lot of like the ex Apex players are Overwatch players.
I mean, said he was an ex-Oberwatch player.
Yeah.
exactly yeah yeah too you're the next overwatch player i
remember i used to watch you in overwatch wait true we have
a chance wait we have our own celly except let's go exactly
except the original celly might be better but like we have
our own i'm not too sure i'm not i'm not well versed but
Yeah, yeah.
We have our own semi.
In a 1v3, perhaps?
Yeah, yeah.
We just gotta make sure he's alone and then we all shoot him
at the same time.
Like we can take that.
Like he's not the pro in his team, but like that's okay.
He's just content creating.
Yeah, he's a content creator like, bro.
Yeah, yeah.
Our team is like the content team.
We're at this point.
We're the content team.
Oh shit.
all right guys excited wait what map are we on i don't oh
world's edge okay all right how good is your zone reading
your ease i don't think we should ask good but really but
like yeah you're like it's pretty shit what the fuck that is
right hello i thought we were like not last place like
that's a good game the ears I believe in you like really
fucking bad are you like the zone reader for your teen years
uh yeah pretty much I pretty much just did everything on my
latest ALGS team oh shit you did everything yeah the IGLing
the entry the zone read the mental care the mental mental
how's your mental yeah uh the mental care was like the half
of i algs and then after that half of it's like i was broken
i needed someone i needed someone else to do the yeah that's
why you're you got after pro league you went to overwatch
the best game for men yep and and guess what egg yep that
did not help yeah i'm gonna say overwatch is not known for
mental care just say
like become very just immune to toxicity or you become the
toxicity oh yeah that's so true that's a good way to
describe it yeah yeah yeah because i i know that like people
be like yeah i came from overwatch and you're like oh i i i
get it man should i be this dude's friend oh my god it's so
true it's like which part of overwatch the the really bad
side or the good one which overwatch which type of overwatch
player are you at least you didn't come from na valorant i
don't know if like jp valorant is any better but like na
valorant is is a whole new side of toxicity um i remember
playing in beta in na that was funny it's kind of thing it's
like you just breathe and they they start like grossing you
oh true true My first day on NA Valorant, I got called a
gamer word and I was like, all right, I'm just gonna mute
everything.
Why so fast?
I literally just like literally said one word and I was
like, well, time to mute everybody.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, NA Valorant.
Yeah, you see, actually, I've been playing a lot of
Japanese, you know, Japan.
in Valorant and it's not it's not like it's not that bad to
be honest it's just no no one is like it's rare to like play
with a you know a toxic loud guy but they have their own way
of like trolling they have their own way of being toxic like
how so they're just passive aggressive like how so yeah they
talk at like the last second of the game like when you
already yeah you suck fuck you yeah yeah exactly just hold
it in until the last minute like i'm never gonna see you
anyway yeah yeah oh that's how they do it here in japan oh
my god i mean i mean that's better it's better than like
getting yelled at in the beginning that's true just like
yeah because like in valor and you can't leave he can't
leave until like somebody surrenders or like or like play
the full game of someone yelling at you at least they save
it till the end you know yeah yeah exactly that's that's
true that is true all right all right do you guys know what
what team okay so we're playing bloodhound bangalore and and
what again the fly you guys do you play bloodhound okay i
can play wait okay but I'm not on controller, but like, no
one in Asia is really on controller.
So it's not like NA.
Oh, no, there's actually a lot.
Actually, a lot more than you think.
I think it's more everyone in Korea doesn't play a
controller, but in Japan.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
But I think like in NA, it's almost like, it's every team
has like a roller player.
Yeah.
So it's so like, you know, NA tournaments are so scary.
i'll be like hey i'm the m and k player here hello please be
nice disadvantage disadvantage sorry i'm my team sorry for
being a sorry for being a nerf for your team i have the
wrong input never okay usually play i can play do you go by
doky or like oh
All right, all right.
I can't I just not Val.
I can do either blood or blood or being Blood or burn.
Yeah, I play uh bang and then okay.
I do blood just yell at me just micro management for scans
Wait, let me just like watch a little clip, you know, like a
little vaude review A little vaude right before a
tournament, you know That's when you should water view
probably What vaude Let's see, DSG is playing Bloodhound
caustic wraith.
Alright, that's interesting.
That's already interesting.
That's already something that's different.
Okay, but DSG is like meta crafters.
Caustic seems to be the meta.
Yeah, I see a lot of caustic now because of like how fuck
the zones are.
So they have to like have caustic to zone out things.
The roller player is usually on the Bloodhound.
But like, since we don't have a roller.
I've never held a controller in my life man Like actually I
bought a $500 controller And I used it like And I only used
it for not Apex You know those battle beaver controllers
that every fucking Apex Pro That advertised I used it like
one time And I did it for Apex And then every other time
it's just for other games that need controller I can't I
don't know how to do it's so difficult i can't either bro i
get so mad when i'm using control like why the fuck am i so
bad it's like it's like i touch a controller it's like all
right i'm going back to mbk ggs i'm so hard i don't but then
like but then when it hits when that aim assist hits though
oh my god i'm like okay yeah, but it hits it when it hits it
hits like one out of ten fights you miss everything or like
nine out of ten fights you miss everything in that one fight
just one clip yeah and then you're like oh controllers OP
what the fuck is this bullshit and then the one out of ten
it was this is broken
okay from what I've observed we should play um we should
play caustic caustic okay not it yeah i don't know what that
is i don't i don't even think i have them unlocked man like
wait you don't have cause wait what how do you not have
caustic unlock default bro i think i have a million legend
tokens how do you have caustic unlocked.
I don't think I got him, bro.
Oh my god.
Pookie, leave the lobby and unlock it right now.
It would be funny if you leave and they actually start
the...
Oh wait, you actually left.
Wait, where did you go?
Wait, wait, I need to join the lobby.
I need to join the lobby.
I was just shooting him box.
Oh, we were wait, okay.
Just so you know.
You were definitely the last person.
Yeah, heroes, heroes come away, you know?
You know, I'm sorry.
No, I'm sorry.
It's okay.
It's okay, some people, this, this, that one guy had that
wheel, so like, he loaded in last, technically.
We're like, oh, we're like, oh, we're, oh my God, we
literally started because you joined.
Oh my God, I'm so sorry.
Oh, shit.
I'm so sorry.
I was literally just tapping.
Sraping her own to fall.
Wait.
Alright, I'll play Bang.
You can play Bloodhound, Donkey.
Okay.
And Shio, you can play I can play...
What am I playing?
You can play Valk.
I can play Valk.
We'll play anything.
We'll do that.
I can play anything.
We believe in our show.
Give me a character name.
We just did.
We literally said Valk.
different Just give me a Give me a character name We did We
told you to play Valk Okay Valk You don't want to play Valk
No no It was like Play Valk Give me anything I can play
anything Okay Valk Anything Anything Just any Anything At
all Anything But Custic Okay But Custic But Custic I don't
have that guy Maybe good Wait what the heck Why are we
staging Something happened restarting oh look it wasn't you
hey i wasn't the last person yeah even if you joined early
yeah it's never your fault just remember that as a
competitor player it's never your fault and always somebody
else's fault yeah it's never my fault like i'm sorry if we
lose today but it's not my yeah so it was ping um it was
ping like bad rg bad rng yeah battle royale rng no there's
this guy called all wingman please like this dude is locked
in bro this guy's supposed to be punching the entire game
he's gonna use the p2020 bro yeah
my uh you're the competitor bro we probably have to be
fighting that guy for your wingman yeah i'm sorry but you
see a wingman package and you know he's there he's gonna be
across the map heading for it it's gonna be me sally and
this guy yeah yeah there's always like three teams fighting
for fucking packs wait how is team one fair what the fuck
we're team one or oh wait oh yeah i'm sorry i'm hyping us up
i'm hyping us up guys yeah yeah yeah that's right how is our
team oh my god team one what the is wrong with team one yeah
don't look at my badges but like what the fuck is wrong team
one oh team two so technically we didn't count they did
stars from team two team one team two like god damn what the
fuck that's pretty okay team two is actually pretty scary
though like I'm pretty sure is also really good yeah yeah
Toa is pretty good yeah holy shit because I remember always
like meeting her in like you know these like yeah these
custom yeah Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, did you just say for fun tournament?
I'm here dead serious.
You say for fun, shit, man.
You're so, when was the last time you streamed Apex, Tyo?
How serious are you?
Like two hours ago.
Like, okay, before today, before today.
What was it?
Like a year ago.
Wait, I'm gonna look up your Twitch VODs right now.
What do you mean like a year ago?
A year ago Hey, my aim's pretty on point though You're
right, you're right, yeah Overwatch aim travel still You
were literally streaming Overwatch yesterday
Bro You were streaming Bro, I'm looking at your bots I have
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 Bro, how long does the
Overwatch go?
Every day I'm ready I'm locked in Bro, 24 24 days ago you
were on apex oh yeah no for the tournament that we had the
one where ureth got like 30 kills oh shit oh yeah that
tournament okay redo it re-replicate that yeah i got you we
need you to do that again i was speaking japanese that time
maybe it's we can do it better you know since i'm i'm on
english mode now oh you're right you're just think you're
just think you're in pro league again lose blame it on the
igl exactly i don't worry you don't need to tell me that i
was going to anyway i don't know what you're on about but
don't worry i'm so ahead of you i was ready to blame you we
lose wait wait are you in you're so you in are you in uh
japan now yeah yeah yeah i'm in japan okay so you have like
nearly a month yeah so you have the gp ping too oh thank god
all right oh yeah yeah exactly exactly oh yeah you have like
120 30 40 50 60 right what he's just like what wait no no
he's just wait are you asking me yeah no no no no no oh no
i'm on oh i thought you were asking your reese no i'm yeah
i'm on a hundred and a hundred and uh twenty ping yeah i get
this i get the same amount of ping to Japan to uh to East
Coast that's how fucked that's how fucked it is are the
servers that bad like west to east and oh it's like 60s yeah
it's so true I was like what a fuck I literally get like the
almost the same pain from east to to Tokyo is actually crazy
so I'm like it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine house is
burning down but it's fine it's fine I might have to it's
actually it's actually crazy.
I have never played a tournament in apex from NA with less
than 100 thing I've always had 100 thing in tournament even
in any servers how yeah I know bro it's just West Coast
debuff it's like yeah it's just yeah we're actually nerfed
by default there's like no nobody ever put servers in West
Coast ever it's always in the east coast it's literally west
coast debuff or just west coast canadians debuff oh we're
starting oh yeah okay okay bloodhound i'm so locked in wait
where are we landing here uh staging staging yeah yeah yeah
that's like a left of harvest Oh, 2k?
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, dude.
Let's go.
Where the fuck is Bloodhound?
All right.
Wait, am I saying Valkyrie?
Oh, there you go.
Valkyrie.
Yeah, Valkyrie.
All right.
Bloodhound.
What do I upgrade?
Oh, wait, shit.
You're right.
What do I upgrade?
Wait, guys.
I can't ICL that far.
Hold on.
You said both said micro and macro us.
Holy shit.
The one...
Okay, Tayo, you upgrade the one that lets you fly like
higher.
And you just go...
Doki, you upgrade the one for...
The scan lasts longer, and...
What the fuck?
What else?
Wait, there's Raven?
Oh, wait, Odin's glare?
Or the Raven?
Yeah, I think you loot Mirage, Doki, so you can scan the
beacon.
Me?
Okay.
Wait, is there anybody else?
No one else is in Mirage, right?
I'm not going to get fucking run up on, right?
No, no one knows Mirage.
Yeah.
All right.
If they do, I'll get them banned from biggest scars to my
team stream.
I'll get them banned.
You'll get them banned next year.
Yeah, I'll get them banned.
But who's next to us, by the way?
We're going to land right here.
Right there.
I forgot.
It doesn't matter.
We're better.
All right.
It's OK.
You guys will pick up my banner.
Ready if I die?
We'll be fine.
We'll, you know, we definitely will.
Yeah, yeah, we don't have any crafting legends, by the way,
just so you guys remember.
So you have to pick me up.
Alright.
If you guys see a...
Actually, no.
You guys are so far.
I want not to travel back to all of you.
Should I get a repeater?
I have a repeater.
Repeater is still busted, right?
There's a purple stock here.
Yeah.
I heard it's alright.
Her havoc is pretty fucking busted.
Havoc's really good.
I'm gonna grab that.
I'm just gonna wait for a hemlock or some shit.
Gonna start the party.
Ooh.
Party started!
Let's see.
It's looking like a little eastern zone.
summer's love oh dude i got my hammer mozambique that's it
we're so locked in nice wait that's actually low-key strong
i'm not actually okay yeah if you get a yeah if you have a
what do you call this a digi threat you can oh yeah oh yeah
because it's on pistols only now yeah yeah oh wait no there
we go I found it have a havoc all right havoc on 120 ping
let's go let me have time to charge it up there's a gold
heavy mag right here landslides already leaving bro what
okay they're wait I'm gonna I guess I have three bats if
anyone needs any be careful be careful of this team this
team flying tyo they're flying towards yeah you're good i'm
running i'm running oh we have a we have a point here i
didn't realize i have like i have okay do you need a heavy
man no no i'm using a bolt right now there's a flat line
here uh i'm gonna go grab the harvester yeah stuff and then
i'll scan so we know where people are going yep it's okay i
have no clue what you're just said i'm gonna open oh i feel
so confident a little harvester i'm gonna go scan so we know
where people are going i'm gonna get this bin here yeah we
definitely need blue armor oh everybody's going here yeah we
have a good they have like a little good rotate here that
good little rotate uh start going back to um staging okay
staging okay all right I got a hammer point for you, or a
DigiThreat for you there.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
I think, yeah, everybody is already setting up in Harvester
area.
Yeah, they're in Harvester, huh?
I think we keep staging here and, like, fight.
And just, like, slow rotate in.
Oh, hey, there's a...
Yeah.
There's a ball.
Hey, I have a faster reaction time.
Thank you.
Oh, damn.
Who gets the helmet?
Uh...
I get it.
I get it for now.
Alright.
Alright, we'll...
Oh, he'd be right fighting already.
I hope they kill him off, so not...
Turn the big mode.
I can't see who...
Like, I can't tea bag.
Oh, you can't tea bag?
It's okay.
The thing is, you always tea bag.
You always see it.
Doesn't matter who.
It doesn't matter who.
It's equality.
Alright, we'll chill right here.
all right i feel so safe with my luckily the team underneath
us here isn't like a op team you know oh yeah handle them we
can handle everyone yeah yeah we can definitely handle
everybody i i 100 agree yeah i can craft bats here too it's
true uh i have four bats if anyone needs more i need a
sculpt They are flying towards oh tree.
Okay, tree.
That's interesting.
What was it wasn't the boss side like heavily like so many
people right?
Left side isn't looted.
You want to leave the left I'm gonna scan this crawl It's
people too.
Should I get the ultimate accelerator?
You should yeah ultimate.
Yeah, yeah.
Ultimate is always good.
You should you need this No, I have 2x Yeah, I like the
fucking stock scope.
There's a blue heavy here.
Where is another scan?
Oh, there's another.
The next scan we have is Harvester.
That's 30-30.
You know, fuck it.
I'm gonna take the 30-32.
I'm on Nemesis Mozambique.
See where the zone is pulling.
Looks like it's a lava siphon zone.
Oh, those guys were flying.
I think so.
There was like two teams already stationed at lava.
Yeah.
I mean, I guess finding a stock.
All right.
Actually, I'm going to craft a bat too.
I hope I don't get killed.
Dude, I'm so scared.
I'm just like near Uri's.
He's my daddy.
I'm just too scared.
Whoa!
Wait, stop it!
Wait, stop to be on to the right!
Wait wait wait wait wait I can't get to you guys yet I'm
gonna walk up Oh yeah, we have a really good spot I think we
fight this We fight this We fight this I'm heading off to
you guys Posthumous Posture up, posture up I'm moving up I
cracked the bloodhound I'm moving up left Moving up left and
taking space Alright Yeah Don't worry, I'm 5 seconds away
Inside the ship Come here Yeah, I see him I see him I don't
have an angle I got an angle Crack, crack, one of those
cracked Nice, nice I have a good cross here.
I'm buying one thing, them too.
Wait, where did they go?
Are you still inside?
They're still inside.
They're running.
I'm good on me.
They took a zip.
Wait, I'm taking space.
I'm taking space.
Okay, okay.
I'm looking to my right just in case a team walks up.
They're inside.
They're locked.
As long as we keep height, that's fine.
We're going to play for this side right here.
See my ping?
We're going to play for that.
Over there.
On the east side.
We just keep him on the low ground.
Oh my god, guys, we're not last!
Somebody get!
Yes!
Oh my, we're so fucking good.
We're so good at this game.
I'm gonna scan thermal too.
I'm gonna look.
Keep looking at the semen staging.
I'm gonna look behind us.
I'll look at them.
They're not out, yeah.
I don't even see them inside.
Did they rotate out?
No, no, no.
They're on this side of the door.
Okay, okay.
I see them.
Okay, there's a team playing here.
on this side they're rotating out they're rotating now they
smoked out yeah they're going up to the zip yeah you're
going all the way i'm just i'm just oh they're getting shot
at they're getting shot at oh you're shooting them i was
like whoa they're getting shot at it's your reese oh they
they are getting shot at shells here on the roof there's
more cells let me know Right here.
What?
They should...
They're not getting shot behind, huh?
We can't really like commit to this fight because there's a
team behind this.
Oh, they're committing.
What?
Okay.
Let them waste the blood on old.
Yeah.
Just don't take too much damage.
What the sick.
Yeah, right there.
They're getting shot.
This time they are getting shot at.
Yeah, they should...
Yep, yep.
Oh.
Oh, God.
I fucking...
No hammer.
There's a team zipping to the villas.
Oh, shit.
It's a god rotate.
God damn.
Look at the fucking zip onto it.
Yeah, they just fucking...
I have a redeploy.
We have two redeploys, so we need it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't want to use much bullets.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I have four bats if anyone needs an extra bat.
We just chill.
Let's see how this zone pulls.
We don't have to do anything crazy.
go in the tunnel if we have to yeah yeah we have the
redeploy too we need to use it
keep scanning this team yeah i can i'll scan it now yep oh
my gosh they're bunkered up yeah they're heavily bunkered up
they're like free shots anyway but this guy right here if
they push up here if they push up here i'm gonna smoke this
and we're gonna run into the tunnel so we have better
angles.
Oh yeah, you can even play up there.
I feel so safe.
They're running?
They're at the back door.
I'm scanning?
At the back door?
Okay.
Oh yeah, they smoked back at the once.
They're still in the house.
Yeah, we have a decent spot.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna go through the tunnel right now.
I'm gonna check our rotate.
There's a team on height here.
Okay.
If we can somehow get to this fucking building, these
buildings here, we're so fucking good.
Wait, can we make it over here?
Yeah, we buckled, we buckled.
Okay, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Right here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, I believe in you're flying.
All right, we're gonna go into the buildings here.
Ping, ping, ping, ping, ping.
You go through here.
Oh!
Go behind this.
Oh my god, we're fucking flying.
Whoa!
Get to the buildings here.
All right.
Let's chill here for now.
this one okay yeah this one this one just reset we have we
have both these buildings we have both okay i'm batting i'm
gonna watch behind just keep on saying no one no one should
be in these buildings just this team on the height i'm gonna
go to the big one building and yeah i'm watching her back
holy that valve that valve yeah that was clutch yeah that
was clutch there oh my god look at you look at your igl go
all right we're good we're good till next I'm acting
surprised you're easy dude.
You don't believe in your battle.
Whoa!
Shit, okay, I'm good.
I'm okay.
It's the people that...
They were trying to sandwich us, right?
I needed... I'm sure selling.
I'm not fucking going under that roof anymore.
That was scary.
On this next zone close, no one should technically come from
behind.
Okay, I'm just gonna go and stay inside for now.
Let's check if there's actually...
fighting there we definitely push that out out out fuck you
looking he lost the fucking for the you like hit yourself I
would never right here we go let's see them are you about
this yeah yeah yeah both of us both of our teammates are
like watching the other side if I have a three egg I'm
pretty sure yeah I was gonna say it's definitely gonna pull
here yeah we're good we're good we have our you're gonna
have a back old right they're back oh yeah let me just
charge my thing I forgot I had it yeah yeah yeah yeah they
might be pushing us I think we can go yeah yeah I scan I
scan I scan I'm back holding I'm back holding we play up we
play up by this team i'm inside first floor oh me i'm
burning one i'm burning one i'm burning flash flash flash
flash flash flash flash flash flash i'm bumping about i'm
bumping about i'm bumping about oh there's three right here
oh they're all flushed i believe in yours one more one more
he's flush he's flush he's flush be my bat he might be my
bat though where is he he was here he was here last time but
i don't know where he is now okay i got scared here here
here Here he is.
I'm peeing.
He's arcing.
I'm watching right side.
Is there right?
One right?
He's resing.
They're resing.
He's outside.
He's reloading.
He's right here.
On ping.
He's peeing.
He's going my side.
He's on me.
He's over here.
I'm better.
It's outside.
It's outside, guys.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
He knew it was going to happen.
Zone.
We're gonna reset.
We're gonna buckle instantly.
All right.
Just pop a med kit.
I'm popping up.
Tell me one.
Yeah, right here, right here, right here.
Ready, ready?
I think you have to leave me to die.
You have to leave me to die.
Just leave me to die.
Just run.
Leave me to die.
I believe.
I'm flying.
Can I make this?
I made it.
Oh, you guys got this.
I made it too.
I was like a 14 squad still.
We're, how am I alive?
Oh, fuck.
Are you good?
You good?
Come to me.
i hope i am oh my god you guys there's still 13 squads are
you kidding me no some random are they like way in the back
i think i can go to you actually are they fighting are they
fighting no no no no they're they're just like in the arnia
in the arnia yeah just oh oh no way no way they random
sniper man Live to top 10!
I'm never fucking forgiving this guy.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Bro!
My bad, my bad, my bad, my bad.
My bad.
I believe in you, top 10.
Oh, okay.
I believe in you a little less now.
Wait, he has to have meds!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Taya has to have meds.
Hey, two medkits, I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
Who the fuck's this guy?
Oh, that's not our guy.
That's his teammate.
11, 11.
We're almost top 10.
Okay, top 10.
We need those points.
We have kill points too.
Oh, oh, oh.
shoot you.
Yeah, he won't shoot you.
He's too scared.
There's no way he tries to shoot you.
There's so...
No!
We're so close to top 10!
We're really...
Oh my god.
Why did the team push us?
They have a free rotate.
They needed the kill points.
At least we got three kill points, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got three kill points.
That secures us not last.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That should secure us not our exactly Unless we unless we
get last place the next five games, but that's That'll never
happen that'll never happen at least we're not last year Bro
that team that led that got harvested fucking so free Oh,
yeah true.
Oh my god What's going on you can't believe I can't believe
we got pushed there Yeah, I was like, wait, wait, they're
pushing.
Yeah, and I was like, wait a minute.
I thought they were just gonna chill.
I was like, all right, they know we have bowels, you know,
we're gonna like, okay.
Yeah, they're gonna be like, is that free rotate?
Yeah, you know?
Nothing's for free.
We have to earn the rotation.
That would have to be like the fucking scariest rotate.
I still can't believe there was still like 14 squads when I
died.
Nah, yeah, that was crazy.
That was so scary.
This dude's just rising in the middle of the fucking war
zone.
Yeah, waiting to climb up on him.
Like...
Oh my god, whoever's inside is so lucky.
Which team is this?
Yeah, it is.
What team am I spectating?
a big caustic bloodhound team yeah they're on top right yeah
yeah yeah i'm not gonna lie though that fight was that was a
good fight yeah it was yeah i literally did zero damage i
walked in behind them i thought i could get a plane and just
three people just looking at me i was like oh it's good
knowing you guys i was gonna say i cracked three people and
i was like i was like so scared i was like wait we're like
no because you said you cracked them so i was like there's
no way they're gonna there's no way they'll see you you know
there's no way they're just all looking at me it's okay
that's why we have yuris here i had my mozambique out and
everything oh the mozamb wait you didn't get to shoot your
mozamb no i tried it once again bro bro you're 60.
i'm sad okay this team's I mean, I don't know, because like
high ground's not in the, it's not in the, the, the
ringside.
So they can shoot them down.
I, you know, I would, if you didn't say that, I would not
have known and I would not seen your damage.
Is that, yeah, I did like 10.
How much damage did I do?
How do you even check?
That's like from the start where I was like peppering them.
What is 60 damage, bro?
What happened?
bro i was i was warming up in my fucking rookie 30 year body
why isn't it applying here i don't understand i don't
understand why that's a sick ass blood on skin oh yeah bro
that's sick that's getting sick oh my god it's okay it's
okay you we're the content creators guess who one guys guess
who one is it is the sell these team team at least you can't
see the damage at the end oh yeah it's we'll see what's that
cheeky cheeky's also oh cheeky's so scary yeah yeah he's
playing with pinotak
that's three kills not bad we got three kills yeah not last
yeah that's exactly exactly that's all we wanted just by
just by looking at the leaderboard i'm thinking we're like a
little like a little 16th 13th 14th type no i'm going i'm
going top 10 bro i'm going top 10.
not last not last it's not last it's all i want as long as
i'm not last because if you're not first if you're not first
no placements don't matter except for last except for last
what the only positions that matter is first last and
everything in between is the same between it's just you you
participated you were there you're right there no one
remembers the fifth place team or the sixth or the third
place team everybody remembers the first and the last i'm
just picking up a repeater i can't i can't use anything else
just don't pick up the mozab anyone it was that's cursed we
we know now no i'm just so sad i could have picked up a
mastiff but i'm like no this mozan is my life yeah you're
you're you know what mozam's the way to go and you're like
you know what you're right listen listen listen guess what
guess what it was the igl's fault yeah oh yeah it was you
reese you told me to get the mozambique that's my bad you
know that's my bad that was you you told him he had a chance
to actually do damage i'm sad all right now all you have to
do is do is do the opposite of what damage all right what
where are we landing on stormpoint are we playing same comp
uh same comp yeah um actually yeah yeah i like our bug bro
if if we just didn't get you know cocked by the fucking
people running at us you got you got cock blocked by who
were they it was it was team satsuki team 15 who is team 15.
i was it was tapping it was tapping oh no no team 14 team
14.
okay i was gonna say yeah they have fish go it's
understandable it's understandable no they have satsuki
that's understandable oh is that supposed to be yeah he's
the controller brain bro oh yeah let's just run it down guys
yeah just run it down i'm the wrong at the aim assist.
It's alright.
It'll lock in for us.
They're like, that team, they saw us shoot them, and they're
like, that team's mouse and keyboard.
We got this.
Yeah, they saw, look at that guy with the Mozambique.
Look at that guy.
60 damage.
Look at that.
They saw the Moza Mican push this.
Yeah.
Oh, true.
They saw the Mozambique.
Look at this dude.
He has the Moza.
Just run at them.
I mean it weren't it worked they took you down yeah they
took you down so fucking fast bro they ignored me and killed
you first even though I was like right in front of them that
was actually crazy no they knew the mosa was the threat they
knew the mosa was gonna shred them yeah exactly they knew it
had a hammer point on it they're like oh no gotta take him
down it's okay they're like oh no he's m and k we got this
all right i just i just needed less where are we landing oh
yeah yeah we need a little look at where we're landing you
call this left of lightning rod they call that place like
zoos zoo station who's around us oh my god where is it okay
our broadcast team oh yeah nice we can kill
In other words, we could kill them 20th place.
Let's see.
Where the fuck is the...
Where is the map?
I just see Storm...
Oh, there's Stormpoint.
Okay.
Wait, they're not near us.
I don't even see 18.
16, 13, 15.
We have 16, 13, and 15 around us.
We have Tappy.
We have Saku.
And we have...
I always don't know how to pronounce 16.
How do you pronounce 16's name?
F-chan.
F-chan?
Okay.
Like C-H-A-N.
Ah.
We're in.
Guys, we're top 10.
We're top 10.
We're in.
The three kills.
Our three kills.
Put us up there.
Wait.
Wait, where are you getting this info?
Someone in my chat.
Okay, the source is chat.
oh shit wait i'm not sure how reliable is your chat my chat
my chat doesn't troll me when it comes to placements don't
worry don't you don't okay all right we're top 10 let's go
we can do this i believe my goal of this next game is to get
more than 60 damage oh that's that should be fine right that
should be aim low you know so you'll always be surprised
i can't wait for the solos and we can watch your ease yeah
we just okay guys let's not let's not it's gonna be like
comms comms and then we're just like having a conversation
yo me and doki's duos is gonna go to oh we're so fucked i'm
sorry it's my fault wait can you like watch it you can you
can spectate us right or like you have to like we have
screen share for you because i assume like yuris can't do
spectate or he'll like ghost for us i would never do that if
you're like i would never do that and i just like it's
supposed to be like your your pro player is supposed to
coach you can we land here or no yeah you just hear me like
whispering like yo there's a team you know there's a team
the end guys the end zone is like everything.
Yeah.
God spots open.
God spots.
Nobody's there.
Yeah.
Because I was like, because it says like your, your coach is
supposed to coach, like your pro player is supposed to coach
you.
And I'm like, how?
Can we screen share?
Oh, really?
Oh, fuck?
I'm about to have like 10 tabs here, bro.
Yeah.
Just, you know, just don't stress me when I say land there.
probably i know but i know he's like hey you know you know
that area over there you should totally land there you know
this my gut's telling me that building is open your gut is
telling you
yeah my gut is like my second monitor
i have i have a hemlock with uh gold or purple what the heck
oh my god give us this landing spot it just has nothing
anyone need this rng i have there's so many havocs i have a
yeah i want the havoc i think carbon i might alternate i
need a fucking different second gun um okay yeah i don't
have a second gun here i haven't i trapped an alternator if
anyone wants it oh there's an r9 isn't that dog yeah but the
mozam dude yeah yeah dude guys don't pick up the mozam or
you get like 40 damage i picked it up i picked it up oh no
definitely gonna get 40 damage now did anyone look at the
backside yet uh that's that no not all the way down now but
we're so okay we're not that far from zone thank god um
let's see yeah i think we're gonna go for this hand and get
that little um harvester go back to zeus get this little we
need we need purple so bad yeah wait they actually i think
they had purple when we fought them i don't remember yeah
they did they did that team had purple yeah they were gaming
i'm running carbine prowler i should be good with my loot
unlock mozambique like the prowler yeah prowler's great
respect you have controller what the heck no i respect that
actually great man i just need to hit one shot one beat
burst and we're fine that's like almost a crack all right i
mean oh i'll scan that i replay for this beacon scan and
we're gonna go they haven't looted it yeah harvest yeah if
you see a better shot than a fucking lozan let me show there
you go got you bro i got you i'm never letting you be on the
lozan and before he does less damage zero zero where the is
the oh there it is i was like where is this i'm scanning
yeah we're there recovering well that's a gold oh
everybody's heading here.
I think that's the... Here or Cito?
Is that a pylon or Cito?
Yeah.
It looks like a pylon.
It looks like a pylon zone.
Oh, we are... We're gonna get purple, guys.
Let's see the dogs here.
Alright.
Lightning rod still here.
Oh, I'm gonna grab the harvester with Evo.
Because it's right next to me.
Get some attachments here.
Should be fine.
Oh my god, everybody's there already.
These guys... I don't see the doggies.
I forgot like uh jp servers everybody just rotates yeah
actually we should go up now it's kind of zones can't kill
me i'm gonna take this cannon take the cannon here let's go
up here we're gonna play for this evil harvester over there
and scan the beacon again look at this guys oh my god such
great idea don't worry if we like thank you thank you if we
do like and like NA, IGL, they won't expect it because
they're so used to JP, JP Strats.
We're the NA Strats here.
What the fuck is this team?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, it's the NA team.
It's an NA team.
What's this team still doing outside of Zone?
English speaking team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of course, the NA team is still out of Zone.
Always out, of course.
Never out of course.
out there zone healing we're not getting ratted here yeah
that's not that's not a thing that ever happens yeah no way
even though you guys have oh we have blue armor nice yeah
we're up bro up in the world are you in the spiders we
should do spiders and then we're gonna rotate there as well
yeah we're almost here i'm just running around i don't know
the map or the building all right i'll go scan there's a
nemesis here in front of me if anybody wants that i'm good
i'm baptist all right scanning oh yes give me all the
extensions oh there is definitely pile hunt there's a uh
digi here there's a team there oh i can't put it on my mask
i'm good oh i'm good oh my god there's like a team here
there's a so oh there's a full team yeah it's definitely a
pylon zone looking like a pylon zone guys definitely does
yeah um seems going for this rotating uh i think we should
rotate towards low um storm catcher okay but here i need a
bat i don't know what there's a uh oh here you go here you
go up four cells here i have uh two bets now i have four i
have two okay uh a little slow okay i'm gonna check this
cannon right here oh another bat there another bat there i'm
gonna go take it yeah you can get it grab it you go there
you go let us go well I'll grab this bat oh dude if I had my
fucking mozan i would have got that no resist the mozan
temptation resistant i need like a heavy mag um a prowler uh
for a prowler ready uh i'm ready yeah heavy mag or the
prowler i need a heavy mag wee all right we take the zip
towards storm catcher too okay do you hear like punch
boosting is sort of back because of a bug oh really i don't
know if they like revert it but like apparently punch
boosting was back for a bit wait i think it is i know it
feels like it yeah i felt i felt a little faster there it's
placebo yeah it's placebo yeah yeah i think so i think it is
placebo are we taking the jumpy Scan our right?
Scanning?
Scan our right side real quick?
Okay.
Paul got scared the fuck out of him.
We're playing for this harvest.
I heard someone.
Maybe they're below us.
Oh.
Do we have a bird?
A little birdy?
Nope.
We're gonna play for this beacon scan under on low ground.
Oh yeah, there's a team right there.
I don't see it.
We should scan it right now.
They zipped up on this height.
All right.
Let's see, do I do a tactical cooldown or taste of blood?
Gain 25 HP or reduce tactical cooldown?
Tactical cooldown.
I think no one's here.
Scan the beacon.
I'm going to take space here.
I'm going to go for here.
Oh, Punch Boosting's back, baby.
It is?
No, I don't know.
I'm just fucking skewing bullshit.
Bro, I got so happy for no reason.
It feels faster, though.
It does feel faster, yeah.
Okay.
Scanning?
No one should be in this compound, I think.
I don't think.
I mean, I don't see you.
Think they left.
Yeah, everybody's here.
Yeah, we're good.
Steam here.
No one's in pylon.
No one's in.
Wait, let's go.
Let's go.
We're gonna, we're gonna hold from this cannon right here.
We're gonna take this, this, this side of the building.
Whoa.
That's so scary.
Okay.
Yeah, that is scary.
That is so scary.
I know.
Trust me.
It's so cute.
i trust idea and we're gonna get in this year i trust you
with my life i'm sweating right now i'm actually scared it
all comes down to this fucking buckle we're here we're here
just ping ping okay ready let's go yeah yeah i will i will
yep just go over this hill for now all right the first step
tired to go over this hill oh wait did someone just take it
no no we're good we're good we're good we're good we're good
wait i think they're taking ping ping we're good in here Get
in here, get in here, get in here.
There's one in front of us.
In front of us.
Where are you?
Come here, come here, come here, land on me, land on me,
land on me, land on me.
Yeah, I landed, I landed, I landed.
Oh, Taro did not land it.
Well, you beat the rock, but...
Okay, I have gold, I have gold, I gold, I gold, I gold.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Cannon's side right away.
Yeah, I don't want to stand, I already use it.
Oh, I don't want to stand, I already use it.
Oh, I don't, I'm a door, I'm a door.
Oh, I'm so...
Paying that side for now.
Oh.
No.
I can show.
Showing.
Oh, yep.
I don't know, man.
That...
I have my...
That timing.
Someone flew as soon as we flew.
It's okay.
We're not last.
Yuri's the rat.
Let's go.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Wait, they're gonna know.
Don't know.
They'll never know.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Tell me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
I don't want to move.
I'm scared.
Wait, you should die.
I should die.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, fine.
Okay, okay.
All right, I'm dead.
Here's an armor swab you're raising.
you go did you did you take my armor swap
you took mine don't worry he has like two more oh he has
another armor swap there you go
you should die yo i already left i already left bro leave us
alone you gotta worry about something else oh oh no the
timing bro they took the building yeah at the same time they
like yeah they did they landed as soon as we like flew yeah
they they got there like before us one second before us bro
the timing they were like going they were like going to the
tree but they like stopped and then you went back to the
building instead yeah they knew they're like this is some
early easy kp right there we could have fought them though
but you got shot from the height yeah i just died to someone
else yeah he was like come here come here ty is just like
three meters away from you i went to the the ping and then
And I was like, oh, wait, Yuri's is not at the ping.
Yeah, I think I'm right.
Because they got there first.
Yeah, yeah.
And then Yuri's and I swerved because I was like, there's
people there.
Maybe we shouldn't go there.
Taya, you listen to the IGL too much.
Yeah.
You have to think for yourself.
Can't comprehend.
You gotta let your rat brain come in and think against the
IGL.
sometimes because like Yuri's left us to die I couldn't I
couldn't get my plus 60 damage I just want like that one
that one was that one was the IJL's fault I don't know there
seems to be pattern all right all right all right i don't
know it seemed a hundred percent like so good and then we're
just like dead dead we got we got purpees we're ready to go
we looked so healthy and in two different teams shot at us
it didn't matter yeah we couldn't even fight man we got i
didn't we got a single bullet i didn't see that would have
been an honorable death but we just died by everyone in the
lodge yeah everyone just wanted to everyone just wanted to
kill us our booties were just too too much it was we just
looked so juicy that one kp the one kp no one no one gp like
look at that easy kp how are they not in zone yet it's like
where are you guys watching i'm watching i have no idea i'm
watching valk bloodhound being yes me too i am l-i-k-e oh oh
l-i-k-e like yeah how do you pronounce the phonetic yeah
like like like that yeah that's who we're watching okay if
they win if this team wins then we die to the best team in
the lobby yeah exactly yeah yeah so technically we're first
too yeah because we're watching them yeah yeah we oh my god
they're pushing oh they have to because they're in zone yeah
okay please don't die oh this guy is so dead this blood yeah
this guy is dead he traded though oh no holy we got to the
12th place team oh yukyo's dead for sure too oh yukyo oh
he's dead oh yeah he is oh he's Bro, what is this zone?
Okay, at least it's not...
Oh, he's so dead.
Anytime there's a pylon zone, it's so scary, because there's
only cover in pylon.
Or is this Bangalore.
Or you guys want this solo Bangalore?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The solo Bangalore with Craver?
This is just one some KP, bro.
Oh, my God.
There's a Watson team.
Is Watson meta, or are they just fucking big brain?
They knew the zone was going to be in buildings.
Yeah.
Yuris, this could have been you, man.
It's could have been you.
It could have been us.
And we should have ratted here, all of us.
Yeah, just in this corner.
We don't shoot our guns.
You just kill his Bangalore and just sit behind this crate.
Oh, my God.
This could have been us.
How did I drop there?
So after this, are we playing duo trio?
I did solos first?
I think it's...
Okay, let me check.
Yeah, yeah.
Idiotic adventure.
Wait, six games, though, right?
Oh, hey, Will.
Will said our translator, well, my translator, because you
two can read it.
He said that it's going to be watched for the solo duos.
Someone's going to do a watch party.
And then, and then, like, on Discord or something.
And then, like, we just watch what they're doing so we don't
ghost.
Like, can we talk?
sure yeah because like we could just sing so yeah we can get
distracted will i will ig up for your reese oh yeah that's
cool yeah yeah give me some ideas yeah we'll give you some i
i bro i almost leaked something for the next apex update i
caught myself there oh dude Oh my god, that could be us.
This dude's a rat professional.
That could be us.
Who is this guy?
Yeah, who is this guy?
I would just mad the fuck up and go around that pillar.
Yeah, let's see that pillar.
That could've been us!
Oh my god, that really could've been us.
You scared he pulled out his gun?
That could've been us.
This is literally just never going to peak.
It's actually only seven parties.
I bet you this rat?
This rat's going to get top five.
Right here.
I think it is.
The teams are fighting right now.
Okay, never mind.
You got scanned.
If it's not the team in front, then it should be okay.
No, it's the team in front.
It's okay.
They see this one rat.
They're just going to let him live.
They need him.
They need him to live so they can, this guy can like, uh,
help them damage another team.
That's six.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
360.
Let's go.
He should climb.
He should climb right.
Whoa.
Oh, he tried.
He tried.
Hi there.
Hi.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
He should not climb right.
There's so many people.
He's almost top five.
Oh, he's riding.
Holy shit.
right and there's no one on top of them so yeah oh no oh
what the fuck no oh my god look at the fucking ponzo holy
but this watson this watson team just wins for free bro this
who is it but they they like hard they hard agree for that
one rat they literally again bro it's cheeky nice this man
plays so many rank like his brain is on another level he's
been trained oh my god one few rank grinders
oh my god like i'm watching him he's so smart i was war oh
my god yeah i think cheeky's got this there's no way they
lose this oh my god holy What the fuck?
This dude check his computer.
Hey, check his PC.
Check him PC, bro.
Jeez, back to...
Wait, was he back to back first place?
Back to back, max kill point.
Max kill points.
Oh my god, bro.
This dude is not playing.
He's not.
He is...
He's Apex.
He's Bpex.
Thank you.
He is...
Just give him the prize.
Just give him the prize money already.
Just do it.
He's literally...
He's literally playing for a fucking second place.
Yeah, yeah.
We all just play for a second and third.
Holy.
He had 18 kills!
Oh my god!
And then there's us over there.
Where are we?
You know where we are.
You know.
We're not last, though.
We're not last.
neighbors are last oh yeah guess what guess who's last yeah
yeah you won against celly we won against celly we did we
did better than celly that's already a win our celly is
better right zero damage celly zero damage celly my average
for two games is 30 damage I put up.
You're right.
You're having 30 damage.
30 damage.
Can I have that set?
After one month of Overwatch.
It's like, this is your brain on Overwatch.
My brain just can't comprehend zones.
I don't understand Like where's the windstorm bubble Like I
need I need some I need some healing Where's the support?
Where's our heals?
Where's our mercy player?
I need the pocket You know?
The pocket Mercy pocket I just can't You know you're the
mercy now 30 damage Lowest damage guard is the mercy pocket
Dude I have the lowest damage in this lobby 100% last place
like a little bitch but to cry.
It's okay.
There's no way we have duos after.
We have duos after.
There's no way.
Wait, is it already the solo?
No, yeah, so I think so.
Yeah, because everybody's leaving.
Are they all kicking us out?
Oh, yeah, they're closing.
Okay.
Yuri's has to screen share.
That's the screen share for us.
Oh, they had the code.
Oh, yeah, we can't.
we can't join yeah wait i feel like okay but like what if
like we just watch iris like how do we show that on stream
like how do i show that on difficult guys you're just gonna
hear us commentate over a blank screen yes guys this we're
gonna be commentating on the black screen
like how do i how do i show this how is that like who's
who's on our the the duos who's that in do uh celly yeah
that's what i'm saying celly's celly's part of the duos how
is that but i have my own celly right here yeah yes sir yeah
my serial damage celly back okay you're you have the screen
know i have a one pc set up let's see but to play on 3 30
fps wait you have a one pc setup wait you guys have multiple
pieces what's going on actually like we know i have one pc
never yeah i was okay but you're a pro player that's not pro
you are you went to pro league you're pro player you should
have dual pcs my setup here is single pc so okay guys you
won't be able to you won't be able to see what your use is
doing on my screen so so you're just gonna trust my word on
everything that's happening
oh my god how many people are it's 20 20 20 teams right yeah
and solos i don't leak the code
have 30 teams of solos holy shit yeah i mean i think that's
the same as they're just using duos mode for solo they're
just forced starting it we love map are you playing limbo oh
shit where do i land everything is predetermined yeah oh i'm
landing fucking phase driver nice yeah phase driver's nice
wait what's your solo character I'm playing Bathfinder I'm
playing what Bathfinder A little Bathfinder fun I believe
Little Widowmaker I believe Wait didn't that new character
came out?
What's their name?
My Something?
The one that digs in Overwatch?
Oh Venture?
Yeah yeah the Venture of Overwatch oh yeah there's a venture
wait no no no it's not venture that's fucking apex yeah i
was gonna see i mean it right i'm stupid like i have a i
have a brain that's like the size of a peanut bro it's okay
you're an overwatch player yeah it's like it doesn't like
one and one doesn't like you need a small brain to be good
at overwatching that's true you can't have both yeah it was
on instant main yeah just turn off half like of your
receptors in your brain and then you'll be good at overwatch
how have you tried have you tried them out yet yeah it was
really fun it's actually like a dig are they op or is it
like like i mean sure like i know like overwatch characters
on launch are always like overpowered as because either
they're overpowered as or they're like the most useless dog
ever yeah no in between that's true that's true true how has
oh yeah yeah wait no you go first no i was wondering why vdk
is here vdk team 18 he's like a streamer he's not pro or
anything is he the solo is he yeah this is it you're a final
where they land everyone's fucking rose in this guy like
team 18 yeah
bro the people in riddle are bullying teammate team yeah
that's their boss they're bullying oh really yeah yeah it's
their boss it's their team owner yeah they're saying you're
not supposed to be here let them play let them play it's
funny though you just like where are you going your ease you
got phase driver he's driver oh very nice yeah yep is it the
same for us too no we're on a different map right no we have
a different map it's okay your ease will igls oh yeah are
you allowed to yeah because like he's just going to be
watching our screen share he's going to watch me whip ten
shots Yeah.
He's literally going to come over to my house.
He's going to come over to my house and beat the fuck out of
me.
No, he's going to come over to your house and play on your
feet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Turn off your cam.
Yeah, turn off.
Turn off your cam right now.
I was like, wow, I'm tired.
Your aim right now is so good.
Wow.
Yeah.
The things we can do because he's in Japan.
Just.
just take the uber right now to tie his place guys i'm here
it's okay is it gonna start he joins the iris joins the
discord on his phone so like no one will know oh yeah smart
yeah yeah
is it i know next scars tournament you should do that like
yeah i'll pretend like i'm igl
all right guys for people who are like what the fuck is
going on let me pin this message your Reese is in a solo
match yeah we're just watching and I can't
and I'm watching via discord's creature little sculpt set up
now let me in I swear I won't ghost I swear I won't tell I
won't tell people where you are
I should be allowed to spectate let me in let me in let me
spectate dude I just realized I just fucking suck at this
game man you just realized hey come on man come on man I
played a little bit started let's go let's fucking go
Alright guys, you're just gonna have my commentary next to
nothing.
Can you guys see it?
Yeah, I'm watching.
Yeah, we're watching.
Let's go.
Alright guys, the map is Olympus, by the way.
I mean, your PC is pretty tanky, right?
It can Discord, stream, share, and stream, and play Apex at
the same time.
Yeah, it should be fine.
Yeah, it was just here.
Just disconnects from Discord.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I turn on the news and I see his computer on fire
with his house.
Everything just blows up.
You know, like, the people who aren't doing Discord screen
share, they're serious.
They're actually like...
I want every bit of FPS right now.
Holy shit.
Yeah, there's, like, some people that aren't Discord screen
sharing, and then they're just, like, they're just, like,
just watching.
my stream just yeah five second delay i don't care i don't
care just watch the stream
you're not the pro player here i don't need the igl all
right guys wait okay you guys are gonna be able to hear the
game too chat don't worry you're gonna be able to hear the
game just not see it
okay you're used to tabbed out so i i can't hear the game
yeah i can't i can't hear anything though Yeah, we can't
hear it.
Yeah.
Oh, no, we can hear it now.
Don't worry.
I think once you start talking, it goes away What the fuck?
Oh, yeah, what the fuck?
That's so weird Discord Maybe it's just your Lisa setup No,
no, he needs to be talking like constantly talk.
Oh, wait, I have to be fucking talking for you guys to hear
it Yeah, that's so funny Hey, stop not talking.
Does that push the talk on?
And then just have a, like, get a rock or something and
just, like, put a button on it.
Guys, you're going to hear, you're going to hear, like, some
parts of Yurisa's fucking gameplay whenever he talks.
Because that's when the sound comes out.
Wait, why is that a thing?
It's so fucking...
Is it because the server is a Nitro boosted?
Is that why?
Oh, maybe.
Wait, that's a thing.
Bro, I'm going to put your audio on the background from your
stream.
It's like a little five minute delay.
Yeah, the little five minute delay.
Oh, wait, they're going to hear, like, your voice, too.
No, I should just watch Ereus' stream on Twitch.
Yeah, but then we're going to hear his voice on the stream.
Oh, yeah, true.
I can mute.
it in discord yeah i'm just gonna try it no no you should
try you need our input you need our input here okay okay
okay don't worry you want me to stop streaming on discord
now no no no we want to walk i watching you on the screen
the share all right so yeah we need that those five that
five seconds is so important for us to help you that is true
that ain't live i'm i'm just i'm just gonna watch the
discord stream with the scuff.io scuff all right where's
endgame what do you think endgame is
oh would you even have any beacons wait you're just muted
himself oh wait i do but man my loot is ass can i scan this
shit oh you're a robot you can't he doesn't need blue armor
for the to pick it yeah yeah you use the blue armor first
it's go pick up the powder all right guys don't worry i'm
gonna play i'm also gonna play it guys just pray for my
heart i just pray for you i'm praying oh i scanned the
fucking don't worry guys i'm gonna play a game as well while
i watchery so it looks like uh so it looks like we're
commentating on my gameplay wait you can do that what
happened to the what happened to the fucking drops it's just
gold gold and shit no the first the first drops are gold the
first one are gold and then oh no oh no yes you're supposed
to feed the riddle team no yeah you're supposed to feed your
teammates is your 20 player in q and what the there's no one
playing apex should do away apex can't be dead there's no
other game alive right now
good aim yes very nice actually this is You got a really
good drop, because you can just farm the balls.
Until another solo pushes you.
Yeah, there's someone closing that compound.
I'm scared of just getting ratted on.
Scary.
Yeah, solo is, like, super paranoia.
That's the scariest thing with Zelda.
Yeah.
Dude, it's a fucking horror game.
It is.
Yeah, it is.
It's just so quiet.
Yeah.
At least you don't want armor anymore, because, like, that's
just instant.
to death as a solo yeah
get another phase driver they're for sure the ratting in
that how the did like you how the did like you have found
them anyway what the did they did did you think he actually
ran at at where the the team owners like drop spot was and
just to kill yeah i mean yeah they had yeah because i was
like how the did he died so fast it just walked he got like
one gun and he's just like i'm ready to i'm ready to take
his i'm gonna take his loot he must have had a good landing
spot if they're willing to take his loot i think so i think
so oh nice
you're used to if you die right now you're gonna have the
same score as me, unfortunately.
So don't die.
Zero damage?
Our team average is here to pull down right now.
Our team average!
It's terrible!
Let's get it.
Not last, guys.
Not last.
Shining shit is actually so scary.
I believe in you.
Did turbochargers drop from here?
I read a turbocharger is bad for the havoc in general Why
because from the I don't know I don't know a roller player
told me this so I don't know how How much I can build The
source is fucking invalid Uncredible sources So I can't I
can't uh Oh shit this guy's lurching I'm a feeling he's like
creeping up on me.
Oh no, I have zone You're zoned?
That's good!
You can keep farming phase!
Hold on, I'm gonna get a position right now.
I'm scared we're gonna get pulled up on here.
I believe.
You're not gonna die.
Yeah, I'm not gonna get ratted on, right?
Yeah, there's no way.
If there's a rat, we could go beat him up, IRL.
They're all Japanese.
I am not involved in this.
I'm so far away.
You're automatically...
Yeah, I'm an enabler.
You're like, Toki gave us the idea.
Her NA ways told us to do it.
Oh my god.
I like how you're still farming phase because you have
nothing else to do.
you oh there it is there's already oh there is we're gonna
be waiting for you to fuck it yeah let's get rid of him shut
up it's kind of illegal
oh killed a rat where is he where'd you go
there we go this is like a horror movie right now yeah The
suspense.
I'm scared of getting shot on the side.
Yeah, because you don't know where the other teeth players
are.
Can I fight this?
Because I was getting third party.
Bro, no mate, he did that.
We're either doing the same as that shit.
Yeah, we're like doing the same thing.
and watching this.
I have the most chance of getting third party.
Wait, did he move?
Yeah, he moved to this building.
I don't know.
I lose that fight.
He has a little nemesis.
I have a havoc.
I gotta charge me.
Yeah, he has the ping diff too.
I mean, you're both in JP though, but he has more shots into
you.
I guess you could just chill.
He's not in there though.
Yeah, 100%.
Are you fighting?
Oh, oh, Tony has died.
Okay, we just killed.
With the repeater in solos, what the fuck?
that's that guy is so confident i'm not gonna lie yeah that
is so confident he's so confident no one's gonna fucking get
like run up to him
holy shit i can feel my fps fucking dwindling down oh no oh
no it's okay we don't want a screen share we'll watch from
your stream you just too late But you can always stop!
No, that's...
Oh my god, your game sound like trolled me.
Whoa!
No, it wasn't trolled, there was actually people behind me.
It's okay.
Shit.
Yeah, this site's so sketch.
This game is so sketchy.
It is.
it's a good little cubby no one's hiding here right um oh
you can rat that's a bad angle what
do you have
oh nice oh nice you can tell me you're so much better whoa
whoa whoa who's this guy
getting shot at got this
little top eight
took the thing oh shit that guy's got a little
oh my god yeah dude he actually creepered me bro he has a
little digit threat bro yeah top eight and the creeper man
it's okay that's a good shot yeah it was a good shot yeah
Was it like two different solos or was he the one that we
wouldn't be wanting him Yeah, it was a one big one.
He hit the craver and then just he hit the craver.
Yeah, once he got that craver shot It was GG's.
Yeah, that's over.
He got it.
Oh You just farming points now.
Oh my god.
Oh You kept ah the craver man Dude, everyone's just hiding.
Yeah, everyone's scared.
Oh, holy shit.
Wait, that was a blue armor though what the heck i did not
die yeah not headshot no it was a headshot wait what there
you was it was 189 to a blue what the wait math god damn it
i got fucking octane styled on oh yeah that guy that guy
can't that guy can't even do anything he's just in smoke oh
my god you kev is actually fucking farming
holy shit he does not care bro bro what the fuck oh my god
if he hit that that was so good if he hit that holy shit
that would have been a montage no you kev you're no that
guy's scared that guy got scared you're scared it's creamer
we're why are you so scared oh dude he's on the boat
my it's okay he has no he's dead yeah 1v1 it's a rev 2 what
the fuck is that what is he holding well yeah did he have
like a bangler heirloom no that's the new that's new
heirloom the the knife thing oh my god he's like destroyed
him too holy that fucking horizon cube
oh my god all right wait why did that guy not use his old he
got scared he got scared oh my apex crash i just realized oh
he got you crashed down oh god yeah yeah
man that sucks losing to i hate losing to a fucking crib he
better have it's okay it's like almost like you got third
place you know it's almost like That is true.
That is true.
I mean, you start on that one, guys, though.
That's all that matters.
Yeah, that's what matters.
Listen, I want my 1v1 to Tappy.
Guys, yeah, remember, he won his 1v1.
That's what matters.
That is what matters, guys.
That's all it matters.
He won the 1v1, guys.
He won the 1v1.
Oh, no.
My apex is crashing like a madman.
Wait.
Oh, no.
wait not now not now we have duos well i'm gonna leave this
fucking quick play game i'll watch you guys now it's my time
to i yell yeah i'm jealous okay there's a new lobby code all
right i'm sorry to this one team good luck good luck randoms
hopefully it doesn't crash hopefully it doesn't crash No
crash, please.
Rise of Hayao, you have, like, you always have problems with
it.
Yeah, no, I always crash.
Right?
Right, yeah, yeah.
It's, like, always been like this with Hayao.
It's like they don't want me to play.
It's, it's, sorry.
The Apex is, like, known to be, you know, not the greatest
monetized game out, like, not optimized game out there.
You know, the optimization is just not the best.
just want me to go back to overwatch like that's so up okay
where are we landing wait where are we landing uh duos
olympus one oh face driver face driver oh we got face driver
too we're gonna share face driver is it is it is it not i
think it's exactly the same yeah okay nice all right i hope
because we'll come to play we'll come to we play you use
coach yeah coach coach um actually wait wait i've learned
this from experience duo is way sweatier like it's actually
like a trio game so something that could like get in you
know like a little get in zone and like a valk blood or
about bang maybe valk blood for like the scan you know okay
okay okay so i'm gonna leave the lobby and i'm gonna go the
bathroom real quick okay yo me too but you're used to
entertain or chat what the what the heck hey guys um welcome
what the is that entertaining yeah you guys enjoying this
tournament um like and subscribe the chat in the channel if
you haven't subscribed how do you enter entertain a chat
usually chat just entertain themselves
streamer listen listen listen this is what i think all right
i think i think a chat chat is is like an embodiment of
their streamer i think um i think i think how you are a
streamer reflects your chat so what's going on here how is
dokie's um chat right here how are you what would you guys
describe yourself tomatoes I see gaslighters we like yapping
oh god
oh shit oh shit I'm running I'm running back why were you
like oh shit oh god you started moving you started moving I
want to know what you're saying.
I want to know what Yuri's going to do to entertain.
Okay, what do I do?
Okay, Blood Valk.
Okay.
I feel like we got to stick together because like, I feel
like if we're separated, they're going to pick us off so
fast.
Yeah, I'm a stupid person.
That is a good strat.
That I have, that's revolutionary stuff.
Yeah, yeah, we just got to stick together.
so we don't individually get picked up.
We just gotta make sure we have blue armor by the time
someone rolls up on us.
That's true, that's true.
I mean, like, you just...
Look at the sky.
You just got, like, super lucky with a zone, too.
It, like, literally pulled onto him.
I might be honest with you.
I actually hate having zones in solo.
Wait.
Oh, I guess, like, solo is a scarier, yeah.
Because you can't just walk up.
Yeah, yeah.
You can't walk up to people.
You have to actually...
you have to actually like look around i'm the one that get
walked yeah yeah i get that yeah okay it's okay if we have
zones as duos then it will be wait there's cheeky yeah yeah
yeah cheeky's the content creator yeah okay you guys are
playing against tally yeah yeah yeah we did you guys excited
i'm so what's the confidence looking like i'm so i'm through
the roof i'm ready you know We're so much better.
Like, I might not have never got rank one, but we're so...
I might have averaged 30 damage per game, but...
Listen, it's time to up...
It's time to up it out right now.
Is it?
I believe in you, Tyle.
You're literally supposed to be, like, the cheeky of our
team.
Yeah, yeah.
That cheeky.
I'm ready to just I'm ready to click on the phase driver
thing yeah my main goal you know I have an advice you know
like just click the phase driver I wish you can get armor
off of that just clicking the button over 50 50 50 50 plus
50 plus 50 we're waiting for we're all here wait why is why
is team 10 three people what the Wait a minute.
What is that?
Yo, Yuris, you want me to stream?
Are you gonna watch our stream?
I'll watch your...
Yeah, we're not gonna...
Stop.
Can't IGL with a little delay, huh?
Wait, can you see this one?
It's okay.
Maybe Tyler's PC is much more optimized.
Oh, shit, there's code right there.
Can you see this?
Did you leak the code?
no no no i never do that i never leave oh there's a code
right there i don't know i heard oh there's a code right
there that does not give me confidence it was just bank
account it's not a thing too big yeah yeah yeah just like
his old logins that's fine
oh wait okay now there's two okay it's we're starting we're
starting literally if we kill cheeky i'm expecting a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank account by tomorrow it's just
all i'm saying just for scars like you better if i kill this
man destroy destroy i come help him right now destroyer 69
all right wait where's phase driver i'm scared phase drivers
like you're east daddy you're right i chill his jump master
wait where am i oh there you go i was gonna say i'm not
being mad maggie wait can i actually no i don't know i would
say bang but i don't know and he said he said blood blood
well i have scans for you right because like i scan and then
and then you you shoot them right yeah it's the plan that's
the plan that's what we said just 30 damage it's okay this
is where you boost up your average that's true this is the
average boosting you're my height man yeah yeah i believe
okay phase driver is right where there no there it is yeah
there i see it i'm dropping eventually oh wait okay what's
the fastest way is it like seven 600 you're he's the fastest
you're over where's your coach you're he's wait go don't
leave us coach is he not allowed to talk he should be he's
just watching us wait what the fuck I can't talk when I'm
watching the stream Bro, what's wrong with your Discord?
Bro, Discord with my Discord.
Bro, we're just like, coach, coach?
How do I see that?
I guess you're just gonna be watching.
No, no, it's a bug.
It's a bug.
There's nothing you can do.
Wait, it is?
I can't, like, fix it?
You have to, like, reinstall Discord or something, I think.
What the fuck?
What is wrong with your Discord?
I've been talking the entire time.
This has been like trying to coach you.
I pressed the button.
I'm pulling out the Sentinel.
Bro, it's Duos.
Why are you pulling out the Sentinel?
Is this not a valid strat, coach?
Coach, we need your help.
Coach.
Coach, I watched your stream, I watched your stream.
now you can wait is is sentinel not a valid option um listen
if you hit your shots it's any gun bro okay and and what was
the fucking track record the last like two games i'm saying
again i didn't shoot i didn't shoot so that is true okay i
guess you can say that well i like press the face driver did
you guys do you look at We need to like, fucking get armors
here.
I'll scan later.
We really need armors.
We can't fucking be going in there with our whiteies.
I'm gonna pull out the peacekeeper.
Oh, there's a helmet here.
Yes, sir.
Okay.
Okay, tire stream is like two seconds delayed.
That's fine.
It's not bad.
Yeah, okay, that's good.
That's fine, yeah.
That should be easy you can you can not you can remove the
stream on yeah, yeah, you can get your ping get the little
fbs My computer's too strong.
It does not care
It's like go for it, bro.
I'm gonna go scan then can you like cover me just in case.
Yes.
I'm coming.
I'm going All right What else can we do to grab our get it?
Oh, wait.
We have to grab the harv evo You guys don't have harvesters
inside that close.
Yeah, we do.
We have one here Okay, I'm gonna scan right now just to make
sure we're okay.
Yeah, we can get the Divo.
It's like after...
Yeah, it's like look around where everyone's like trying to
play.
Where they try and play?
No clue.
No fucking clue.
What is this?
You can scan.
You can scan the drop style right now if you look at the
sky.
Okay, okay.
Yeah.
Uh, wait, where are they?
I think they all already dropped.
Oh, I'm stupid.
We're zone ending.
Where do we go?
Yes.
Just loot towards like the circle for now.
Take your time and play for the next zone.
Okay.
I dropped a 3x.
Every it goes.
Once you see that next zone, find like a little...
I'm gonna use two.
Next to it.
And then you guys play for that, but you can rotate with
the...
I don't know the new system of beacons and shit.
Like...
I thought I could scan it.
Yeah, no, uh...
Nah, yeah.
I think Val can't, right?
I don't remember Val.
No, I can't.
Yeah, because I don't play Val, so I don't know Val can.
I did the phase again.
Just look at cheeky stream.
It's a joke!
It's a joke, but it was a joke.
Turning off echo cancellation.
Echo cancellation.
I hear a car.
Find us.
I'm looking I think they're scanning right Yeah yeah But can
we see the scan from here?
Yeah we can We should be We're not scanning I don't see them
I heard a car They drive past us I mean we have a car Wait
no they did They just scanned They're literally in zone
They're just They're on the car I think they're just gonna
Wrap around right Yeah they should Yeah yeah right we have a
car too um where where's the closest beacon right next to
you guys is there any which one which one's the beacon dokey
uh go to solar array go soda are they do should we take the
car to solar or just walk over uh nah just just walk over
loot everything all right there's no one near us because i
have a crow usually there's a crow to shoot They're still
behind us though.
What the fuck?
They're still in zone.
Yeah They're in front of us.
Can I shoot?
Get that harvester.
Yeah Yeah, they're gonna shot from here.
Oh, they're gonna shot at this well.
Yeah Move left move left toward it's like the entrance of
terminal.
Okay Are we gonna get that?
Yeah,
I think they're just they're just like going around driving
for the either.
Oh, they're People over there.
I have alt who need to fly.
I'm just gonna scan just in case.
If they start fighting, you can third party there.
But if they don't commit, you don't have.
They're not committing.
There's a team right here.
There's a team here.
And there's a team to my right.
I'm like worried I'm getting a shot from her back, so.
I don't see them.
Where were they getting shooting?
Are you guys talking?
Did my Discord, my Discord crowd- I think I'm like higher
central.
What's going on?
Guys, what's going on guys?
What's going on guys?
Everything's going right.
We can fly.
Look at the zone.
Where's the zone?
The zone is a grow tower.
A grow tower.
Here you go.
Is there a team on solar?
Yeah, there's one party.
Look at how they're like what they're doing.
They're not scanning the beacon.
I don't know if they have beacon characters.
That's the thing.
I think you guys take solar from them if they're not there
anymore.
Okay.
We don't know if they are though, so...
Yeah, walk up from the right and then scan them.
Okay.
Let's go right side.
I believe in us.
Let's play for that beacon.
You can even like tank a little bit of zone as well.
it one minute okay oh my god they knocked somebody they're
in front of us and from us in front of us they scan you see
i know us we're here all right back out back up they're
they're right yeah no they're going they're going in they're
running no oh
i can't believe we're so lucky
like that the pills in front of you oh never mind
no he has demons no he had demons oh i was there with you if
i was there with you man yeah you actually fucked them over
You creeped them.
Bro, I can't believe.
Ever since Taya crashed, everything went downhill.
It's a great hit.
It hit all of us.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Almost.
I can't believe it.
Bro, you actually used the peacekeeper like ash.
That is crazy.
Yeah, bro, you should just, you should just play it.
This is hard scope.
He has a hard scope, yeah.
He has an ash hard scope.
Oh my god.
That's so unlucky.
We're trying to fuck over a solo, man.
Nah, that is so fucking unlucky, man.
I know.
In duels.
I've never, I've only had, this is the second blue stream
I've ever had on Apex.
It had to happen now.
It had to happen in the duels.
Yeah.
That's actually crazy.
My second ever, ever blue screen of death.
It was the jinks, the Taya jinks.
I'm sorry.
It's the next stop is Yuri's, unfortunately.
Yeah.
No, Yuri's already got hit with the fucking Discord.
Not me.
Oh yeah, the Discord bullshit.
Yeah, yeah.
What is that, bro?
What is that?
Let's watch that Discord bug, guys.
what's going on here okay we have three more games it's okay
we can bring it back in the next three games i believe i
want to go for yeah yeah wait is there wait no two more two
more games yeah there's two more games two more two more
trios bro bro redo the duos match i crashed restart yeah
redo please thank you wait this game is actually like oh my
god really wanted Taya to have more damage.
Yeah, how much damage did I have?
288!
This game wanted him to have a higher average so they
fucking sent out the assassins on me.
In the middle of the road, Tate 2.
I was like, what the fuck?
That's so messed up.
Maybe we're just meant to be overwatched.
players yeah yeah this game is just telling us we suck ass
yeah like what's your overwatch rank i got one to gold you
got gold my first rank yeah wait have you you're gold that
shit was a scam bro
got scammed you get 10 matches to rank up when you won't
take placements bro it's so cute i got one to go after my
placement wait what's your rank now seven three and all
those games i did good it wasn't like i trolled one of the
games it's just i had bad teammates oh the overwatch special
yeah yeah i just have bad that sounds like a typical dps
main yeah i am indeed a dps man i just i just can't um
what's that word can i do what's that rank phrase i got i
got trolled once by like by a healer oh my god you're in elo
hell bro it's not you it's your teammates that's where
you're stuck in elo hell yeah but like i actually was like i
actually i'm like i like you know i i don't think i should
be in gold you know like i plan them at least release okay
did you rank up the plow you're still in gold i stopped
after i got trolled by a healer bro i like yeah this i'm not
playing this game at all i i i actually i actually raged
went to valorant and rage and valorant no that's called you
should stop streaming yes you know if you had to go to
valorant after rage quitting overrush that's what you know
you need to stop
Oh my god It's okay, gold is like the average Average player
You're average That's the average race I'm average I just
need a duo You know, I need like I need someone to rage with
me I need someone to like I need someone to be there You
just need No, you need a mercy pocket That's what you need
actually i think i have a mercy pocket i'm about to duo it a
friend dude we're about to roll true we're about to get the
diamond you see the mercy pocket this is that's it that the
healer pocket that that's that's the way the oh my god this
team oh this team yeah holy oh my god that's team that
killed you no because they died it's the team that killed
the people that killed me
and they see the best yeah the second to the best yeah
someone my chat was like every gold player say they belong
in diamond dude my gym coach says the same shit like i'm in
gold but like i deserve diamond bro my teammates like the
moment you get that mercy pocket you go up yeah i feel like
moments where you cannot do like you can't do more as a solo
though.
Well to be fair I think like Overwatch has changed because
in the past you can solo carry a team in the past when there
was like six players.
Now like now the way they balanced in Overwatch 2 I feel
like it's harder to solo carry if you're like a fucking god
tier DPS.
Yeah it's just you just die.
Yeah.
You just die.
Especially if you're a DPS player.
If you really want to class being a tank okay tank is
playing tank is fucking miserable but like no one really
enjoys playing tank but like take is like the most
overpowered character now in overwatch i think dps got like
hella nerfed i always get fucking rolled by um that guy that
has the little punching the guy that Yeah, Doomfist.
Yeah, Doomfist.
I always get fucking fisted by that guy though.
I hate him.
Wait, what?
Yeah, you got fisted.
Several times.
We have a 10 minute interval.
I'm gonna go to a fucking lockdown.
Are you gonna go to lockdown?
What the fuck does that mean?
Wait, let's lock down.
Let's lock down together.
I need to fucking roll someone right now or I'm about to
lose it.
oh my god wait yeah yeah that's all wait yeah you guys don't
have me added okay i like you okay leave custom mesh i'm
here is it just dockerbird yeah oh i'm here yeah what is
lockdown oh what the fuck i can't even play wait what the
curse the curse is real the curse is the next she's level
one she's like level one what do you mean i'm 107 and yeah
yeah i think it's you Yeah, it's you.
Go to firing range.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We need to go in.
And then we have to leave because it resets it.
Okay.
Yeah, it's a little, it's a little ALGS strat there.
I'm not too versed in the apex, apex phenomenon.
Yeah, we've learned to, we've learned to adapt to the bugs.
It's not bugs anymore.
It's like how in Overwatch you turn on Vsync on.
on and off that that's the i don't even think that we're
dude punch boosting is definitely back holy yeah i'm pretty
sure it's back oh man like you know how were you you played
overwatch since launch right tyo yeah yeah do you remember
that that that phase where you have to delete your friends
for more fps you remember that oh yeah that was just funny
any friends in your friends list yeah yeah you have to like
keep your friends list to like like one to two pages because
you can get more frames so people had to do that over one
yeah you have too many friends you're getting fucking nerfed
yeah you're like are you a good enough friend to like in to
for the frames okay that was so dumb yeah yeah we go back to
lobby and then and then you race crashes right that's the
whole plan yeah yeah he's gonna crash the next game wait not
trios lockdown okay wait he's so oh okay it's good yeah it's
good now i thought it was so bug Yeah, frames were for
friends, 100%.
To be fair, even if like, you know, Overwatch 2 has gone
through a lot of things, the best thing about Overwatch is
the fact that you literally play any server and you're fine.
The net code for this fucking game is like insane.
It's one good thing, I guess.
Yeah.
Out of the many bad.
But then again, any game, no game is.
perfect honestly yeah yeah yeah 100 i just wish there would
be a new fps game i've been like there's like this uh i
don't know if you guys heard about the one that was from
like runescape devs i know it's weird that runescape devs
are making an fps game but wait what there was a new one
that's come that beta open oh the ascendant have you guys
heard about it the ascendant ascendant yeah let me google it
yeah apparently like like closed beta is coming out like
tomorrow or something or today the ascendant fps yeah oh you
guys heard about that game infinity yeah yeah yeah
apparently it's by some fucking runescape dev it's like apex
movement with like it looks like apex yeah it's like apex
movement with something else i don't remember i saw it on
twitter it was like trending on twitter and it's like oh my
god this game's like two weeks but oh my god just like the
finals
let me uh i want to i want to kill people right now what's
lockdown what game mode is this i don't think i played
lockdown no clue
who's that one last player that's not loading in do i need
to buy someone an ssd right now yeah Give me your address,
boy.
True.
Let me send you a terabyte SSD.
Wait, what's your ring right now, Tayo?
Right now?
Like, Grandmaster something.
One, or...
Not even that new rank they made.
What's that new rank they made?
There's like 10 people in that ring.
Like, champion.
Champion?
There's 10 people in champion?
Wait, really?
No, it's legit.
like 15 people per region per role.
Wait, really?
I thought Champion was like not top 500.
It's like the tier above, a tier.
No, like top 500 is like from Masters 1.
Oh!
Bro, that means Champion is like fucking top 10 or top 15.
Yeah, it's like, it's really like, I don't know, I'm never
getting there.
I'm never getting there.
Bro, what the fuck?
I did not realize that is that cooking yeah no it's like
hella hard you need a three stack or some shit yeah at 3 a.m
when there's no one playing it you just kill all the
master's the overwatch league the overwatch league special
oh i'm getting rogue i rolled one guy my god i didn't shoot
anything yet i don't know where people are what the that's
what bloodhounds whoa whoa whoa Oh, he's above me.
Guys, I'm feeding.
Wait, don't get dropped down.
Yeah, I'm feeding.
I fed.
I don't know what to do.
They're holding the spot.
Yeah, I think you gotta go to the spot.
The spot?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm so...
Oh, like, do you like...
Oh, it's like control, basically.
Yeah, there's...
It's so in control.
Wait, where did the guy go?
The fuck?
Right below us.
Alright, guys.
You're gonna...
We're gonna take her.
Right underneath me dead underneath me right here.
I just fucking fell.
It's fine.
I'm fucking falling before you.
Oh, that's not you.
Okay.
Nice.
I don't care I'm healing.
Wait, this dude is they bubbled inside they literally have
like infinite bubbles.
Go in.
Go go go go go.
I'm pushing left.
I hit someone.
I'm scanning.
I got one.
I got two.
I cracked the bang.
Oh, I got two bang low bang low.
that's another i got three nice oh i can't get more i
cracked it i did everything i can what the oh they have
replay now there's like four parties now yo they we're
getting bro where are we we're bears okay we're second there
go be go be go be go be yes neutral it's neutral i'm heading
over Wait, this is like some...
Wait, we're playing Overwatch right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're controlling the point.
I'm literally running past as many people.
I mean, who?
What the fuck?
Hello, he's on my door.
Oh, he burned me.
How did he play?
I'm so ass cheeks.
Okay, I'm healing.
Don't worry, they're not gonna push, right?
Outside?
Wait, in front of me.
No audio.
Oh, God.
He's climbing up on me.
you you can climb that what the what there's a fervor of
that room hoppy hoppy no i had to fucking charge it up bro
when did they add a replay did you just add it today or like
not on lockdown no i think it's for this game mode maybe oh
they're testing it out must be oh my god dude i can't beat
the the dude with the prowler I'm heading over to neutral.
I'm heading over to B.
I'm in.
Are you not supposed to scope for the prowler?
The prowler?
You can, but not really.
I normally don't.
Oh my god.
I hate this guy.
Yo, hate it's a strong word, man.
There's people on me.
I'm going to B.
Let's meet up and be.
Oh, there's two people on me this motherfucker oh no my
wingman they have my wingy what the fuck is this guy
okay i'm dead let's go yeah i'm scanning i realize we're so
far yeah yeah b b b b b b b i'm dead what the i'm getting
teamed on by five teams you get teamed up oh my god what the
The backups here the backups here.
Back up here.
We need the backup.
Oh, that's you guys.
I'm here.
Wait,
I'm pushing from the left.
I'm flanking.
Me too.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Wait, hey.
Keep me slow.
Slash enemy dead.
I'm gonna bat on the corner.
I'll be dead.
Ouch.
that that what is happening that guy i'm coming over i'm
coming over i'm sweaty as fuck dead bitch you're dead oh
they're coming in they're coming in they're coming in
they're coming on me can we get it there's so many guys oh
my god it's neutral i got it i got it you got it okay i'm
covering i'm covering there's people on the bubble i'm
holding and i'm holding it i'm here he's behind you
Nice.
Thank you.
Oh, okay.
You got planning.
Somebody.
Nice.
Oh.
We're following you.
There's wiii.
Where's the wiii?
This is when I got it.
I got it.
That's right.
Come to me, come to me.
There's four people over here.
Guys, they're gonna take the wiii.
Yeah.
they took your wingy wait just go to a no i'm literally on a
yeah just take it i'm coming i'm coming
nice free zone all right what the heck we got a free zone
yeah we got three zone bro one nice how long does this game
mode two two two two two one high two one high two one
height give me give me right here okay I'm scanning.
I crack one.
I'm moving up.
I got one.
Oh, I can see him.
We can see him.
Oh, nice.
Sorry, fuck it.
Wait, going up.
I'm going to grab that triple take.
Oh, there's an EV!
There's an EV!
I'm going to grab it.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry.
I'm air support.
I'm under Zip.
Under staircase.
Well, I dropped down, guys.
I dropped down, guys.
I fucked up.
This isn't even our point anymore.
Yeah, yeah.
We have to go to B.
What the fuck?
Yeah, the way I had to go to B, I was like, where are you
guys doing?
I'm just chucking nades in there.
All right, it's neutral.
I'm going in.
Yeah, going in.
There's one guy.
Oh, that's you.
Nice.
There's a wingman.
Oh my god, I will that guy.
Wingman.
Wingman, in front of us.
Wingman, right here, right here.
No, I need to heal.
I can't see anything.
Oh!
Sully, go, go do your silly thing!
Behind me.
I'm getting out, I'm getting out.
Holy shit.
I'm giving up the point.
What do you mean?
I'm still on it.
Why did you give up?
Wait, we're winning.
What the fuck?
Wait, we're winning, guys.
How do you win?
We need 500.
We're so close.
Keep going.
Oh, we're not winning.
We are.
We need like 30.
I'm going A.
Okay, okay.
We literally need 30.
We need A.
Oh, you're dying, boy.
Oh, I'm so dead.
Oh, just grab me.
We literally...
I'm going for you.
Come to me.
I'm holding it in for four seconds.
Did we do it?
Come on.
Wait, we won.
We won.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
We saw that.
I thought we were...
Wait.
We finally won something.
You know what?
No matter what happens in the tournament, we won in
lockdown.
Yeah, we won this.
Yeah, I was sweaty as fuck.
This is our win just in time too because we have five
minutes still match.
Wait, we still have five minutes?
No, no.
Yeah, we have like five minutes still match.
I don't think we can get another lockdown in guys.
Storm point again.
What happened in our last Storm point game?
We remember when we tried to land and then like another team
landed on our spot.
Yeah, that's what happened.
Did you just relive the PTSD?
yeah you guys want a shotgun 1v1 a shotgun 1v1 all right
starting soon it's starting soon okay everyone's in i can't
even move there wait someone moved me where's the code leave
again and then join back in oh there we go there's the code
i joined back oh yeah i need someone to move me right now
yeah wait what the fuck i can't move yeah i'm fucking stuck
um don't keep bird can't move team one please team one
please can't move put me in sad i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm
stuck please let me play They put me in the sad corner.
It's okay.
We're not the last team to join the lobby.
Exactly.
Well, technically, we're here already, yeah.
Yeah, we're all here.
I'm just not on a team because I'm stuck.
I'm stuck, stuck, bro.
I'm gonna go get a snack.
We're back.
snack break full snack break what games have you been
playing here other than Overwatch and Valorant is just those
three yeah I thought you were gonna you were not gonna
fucking include Valorant I'm like yeah I call Valorant too
to be fair there's no other FPS games right now yeah I just
do some like IRL streaming you guys were at karaoke
yesterday right yeah yeah yeah dude that was sick yeah
that's true like the karaoke's in japan is like insane
there's like so much you can do there like a professional
singer like i actually like yeah he like makes like anime
music oh like what anime um what do you call that anime a
specific anime is a cute Hokkaido girl um he makes what do
you call that overkill what is that anime that overkill was
it overkill her that name is familiar overkill overload
overload yeah
does like the way you he does like the opening for overload
yeah yeah oh shit but that's sick yeah yeah it's surprising
how like many like famous how many like famous japanese like
celebrities play apex i do i know it's actually absurd
that's crazy i remember that yeah i remember that one
tournament i just finished watching um alice in the
borderland yeah and the guy was playing in it i'm like wait
i just i just finished watching that show the the main
character is playing apex he's in he's in my fucking game
like he's in my game bro like wait crazy he's playing with
that jim So cool.
I remember like when I was in when I was in Japan, like I
went to like the uh, it went to like the apex The apex
fucking cafe and then I saw like a bunch of girls taking
like like aesthetic photos with their like Apex legends
acrylic stands with their food.
I was like, they were like they're like super fashionable
too I was like holy shit like I did not realize like like I
knew apex was popular but I didn't know it was like making
like actual like aesthetic photos and stuff with their food
yeah we're not all stinky gamers anymore yeah like bro it's
not just gamers it's not just yeah yeah what am i playing in
falcari i guess we're going to steam comp right yeah yeah
same comp same comp hopefully we land in a place that isn't
full of people that just landed as well yeah but listen we
had the same you know thoughts they were just like a little
faster yeah we're like 10 seconds faster we we they would
have been fucking in the bin yeah if we were there first
yeah we hesitated i would have like 500 damage at that point
like god damn okay more than 60 damage oh same yeah same the
but this isn't the last no no we have one game after that
please if there is a god of apex legends give us give me
more than 60 down okay i think for that to happen one of us
has to crash i think i don't think it has it's up to the
apex legends god it's up to you ty like you guys don't
understand my struggles You never understand me It's never
my fault Or is that off-limits Yeah, like I mean you don't
want to get shot by these guys land there and do the do the
dogs Yeah, just don't die.
I'm too scared.
I'm scared.
Are you a pussy?
Are you a little bitch?
Yes, I'm a little bitch I'm scared as fuck
Little bitch The Overwatch player being a little bitch I've
dropped the nemesis If anyone wants a nemesis I'm gonna have
a locker Myself See I need like If anyone finds a vault let
me know And they don't want it Gizur Alright Let's see It's
okay we are Hey it's the same it could be same zone it's
literally the same circle yeah they love that fucking pylon
zone huh and this is it looks literally the same as the last
storm point game
oh scan my survey beacon oh we're scanned by here oh good
thing i land there holy i mean you'd be yeah no no no you
would land here they're like here what do you mean oh okay
yeah that's your ping I think I think that was your pick
I dropped a purple laser sight I'll take that okay I need a
backpack though I have low key kind of here without a bag oh
I found is that backpack yeah there's a bag here thank you
try to find a bowl I don't have an L star, a carbide.
Did you loot the back yet?
Yeah, not all the way back.
Where's that?
Where's that, um, what do I call this thing?
Holy shit, laser sight.
I forgot the fucking attachment.
I dropped, I dropped it like all the way over the back
there.
I don't know if Tyra got it.
Did you already got the laser sight?
Okay.
I didn't figure it out.
It's all yours.
There it is.
Oh, nice.
Please.
All right.
We should go over here and then scan the beacon and grab
this.
Oh, there's your hair and lightning rod.
Hiding over.
Let me see.
Ultimate accelerant.
Yeah.
I have one.
I have an alt.
I'm holding one right now.
I just need a vault.
I have a Nell star.
I'm using a bubble.
a boat as well hey i mean i can i can make do a little stuff
for now wait there's a package behind us no that's a crow jk
i like looked at my map i was like wait a minute
gamer here oh you should scan the uh yeah drops to tile and
like wait i can scan
well well if you see it on the sky oh i'm gonna scan see
where they're rotating we go up there yeah oh my god oh my
god they're all here oh this looks like our land launch pad
zone guys what do you think i don't think i listen there's
like there's only there's no one around us too
the closest scan is here
oh you guys are all went up I'm coming back I wanted to yeah
I am 10 seconds behind you want me to give you the bolt no
I'm good I'm good I can work with LSTAR I got good I have a
carbide I found a piece caper so oh okay it's right here
alright doors open here there were people in command center
they might have rotated from there
yeah regretted the decision um so far so don't get into a
fight up i am waiting i want to do the speeder oh wait they
probably did it
I'm heading over right now I'm almost there I have no big
med kits I have two med kits I can give you one thank you
after as well I'll just take one from Houston give me it
thank you oh my god like he might oh my god thank God we're
not 20th that's all that matters oh yeah they did they did
they did the fucking eggs wherever these things are called
the don't scan the beacon right away yeah let's do this
let's do the spiders then we the doors open by the way yeah
sketchy pretty sketch bat here there's two I'll take the bat
I don't have any bat oh sorry I don't have a bat a drug yeah
I'm a little broke All right, go for the beacon scan.
All right, I'll go back for the beacon.
Not last, baby.
Not last again.
Let's go.
We're consistent.
We're doing really good right now.
Yeah, we're consistent.
Where do we go?
Oh, yeah, it's definitely launchpad.
Nice.
All right, we're good.
Team there.
Team about to be here.
They're probably going to rotate down.
do we command center jump or um nah i think we just go down
like normally and then go i want to get this to be honest
which one this storm catcher the last one yeah this
harvester yeah yeah yeah i mean there's no one contesting us
right now yeah i'm right behind you i'm gonna i'm gonna go
down drop right here and then one sec one sec harvester go
ahead I'm ready I'll jump down the other one yeah oh my god
not scared so scary yeah we just land on a full team yeah oh
we're not 19th place as well oh hey we're fucking improving
let's go surviving yeah we're getting better and better oh
there's a drop here too i'm gonna go for the i'm gonna go
for the harvester you guys can go for the drop okay the crow
went this way what oh should i get the golden repeater yeah
yeah do it yeah do it i'll go with ayo just in case we get
ape done yeah i look behind us my crow went backwards gonna
go down in this like uh the cannon I have a lot of
attachments for my hemlock, if you guys want.
Like purple.
You have a 3x on it?
Yeah, 2-4.
Okay.
Wait, what's this?
The cash?
Oh, it makes you purple.
I think you should have it.
Yeah, you should take it.
Yeah, you should have it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
The pro should have this.
Not me.
Wait, did you take it?
No.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I thought you did because you went purple.
I was like, wait, what the fuck?
Be careful that my team coming here.
Yeah, there was a team that scanned us.
I'm waiting for you.
Are you gonna come?
Yeah, I'm just guarding this shit.
Wait, should I take the top of the building?
Yeah, just make sure no team walks up on us.
Just in case.
Yeah, make sure we're not getting mirrored by that team.
Looks clear.
We want them to go on the other side versus chip.
Where do we go next?
Alright, we're just playing this cannon area.
most likely a team that uh i can't really do infighting okay
i'm gonna come yeah i'm coming looking right now i have a
repeater and a peacekeeper so not too great and this right
side i'm gonna look left i can i'll hug this wall and scan
if if no one's on right take space on the right and i'm just
taking okay taking space on the left as well i didn't to
scan anybody all right i'm in i'm in zone here too i'm
watching our back too yeah i'm gonna look if there's a team
behind us would i shoot foster up too quite yeah yeah you're
on repeater you should be able to do you think we could get
that ego or no guys we can we can we can i got 84 damage oh
my god improvement nice watch uh someone watch behind just
yeah i'm watching i'm watching behind for us.
I'll go for the Yeah, Ty, you can look at my friend.
I can, I'll look behind.
You're not in a bad spot on that height here.
We have redeployers.
We have a redeploy.
Yeah.
They're moving.
Where the fuck did that team go behind us?
May have ran to the other side.
Where are they going?
There's a team there, though.
There's a team playing this, like, house.
Where are we in?
We're in right here on that road.
your purple noise hold on uh keep watching our back i'm
gonna i'm gonna scout in front to see like where we can play
yeah i don't think there's anybody in zone at all i'm
looking at the right side just in case the people in front
of us were watson squad so you're if you see the same yeah
there there it's a watson new castle over there just fucking
killing in the corner uh there's no one to turn right at the
moment um all right we have a spot okay we have we have like
decent spot to play how long I'm heading over let me just
confirm it oh they're about to fight I'm looking at our
backs just in case wait okay okay okay we're gonna we're
gonna chill right here on this zone close yeah moving it
moving it come to me wait can I move from the left or no
yeah you should yeah we don't want to give presents there's
a team here like the team playing the building probably and
this is the the Watson team playing in the corner okay they
see me they saw us.
Come to me.
Come to my side.
It's fine.
We have cover here.
Lots of fucking cover.
The steam can't walk up.
Like, the steam can't walk up because they're just going to
get shot by the steam.
I'm looking at this team right now.
Take a face now since they saw us already anyways.
Stay there.
Stay there on the height.
I'll look at the left side first.
Keep watching.
Keep watching the steam on the...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I'm looking left.
I'm going to make sure they don't fucking wrap us here.
Let me show you.
Whoa.
Okay.
I heal.
Ooh.
Is there a...
Can you like move up on the left side somehow?
Is there like a cover?
We a zone.
No, I don't think so.
The cover's not going to best.
I'm going to stay to the right.
Oh, they're rocketing us.
No, no, there's no cover.
No, no, I was looking.
Yeah, there's no cover.
Let me just play it here.
All right, we can fly too.
This...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We haven't read the play as well.
Oh.
Ouch.
How many bats do you guys have?
I just think he's getting shot on the right.
They're getting pushed.
This Watson team's getting pushed right now.
Fuck, okay.
I need a bat.
What the fuck?
I'm going to scan in front of me just in case.
All right.
Yeah, I think, yeah, there.
Because I have 10 damage.
I'm 5 cells, one bat.
I'm gaming.
I have 10 damage.
Are they still...
Is the Watson team still there on the right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it looks like it.
There's a team right here on ping.
That one's hard.
I ain't even finna lie.
I mean, we could really...
the first toy back here yeah we could like we could like
balko from where i am and like look around but they just
rest wait what the there's a team right here where i'm
paying i don't know if that's the same team but that like
got a better angle i'm watching but they're definitely i'm
swinging right to yeah yeah there's a team that's a
different team over there then why aren't they shooting each
other the fuck no gaming they're teeming bro i'm moving up
to the trade should i rotate to you guys no no no they're
still there they're still there no no no no now Should we
fly or say we have 40 seconds i think we have to fly all
right this is the best cover i think great oh no there's
people we just fly We just fight.
Come to my side.
Come right here.
Yeah, right here.
I'm flying.
Yeah, yeah I'm here Here we go.
We got pink for us.
Look around.
We have a tree.
We have a little we have like little trees here So fly like
towards here on the left
Keep flying keep flying I'll see you land land on the second
floor land on the second floor.
We're gonna fight the second floor.
I'm gonna go in the door I'm gonna go in the door.
No one's here yeah that's our house our new house our new
house yes yeah okay this door's open it's fine it's fine we
have a house we still have a door here i'm i'm chilling on
this door wait somebody's knocked you see that someone's not
wait i'm gonna i'm gonna peak alone i'm gonna okay okay here
don't let your east die protect your east okay okay we just
show we just show don't do too much if we hear them raise it
if we If we hear them resing, we peek, but don't commit to
the push.
Okay, I can scan in two.
I'll scan again.
Oh, we have zone.
Oh, no, they res, they res, they res.
There is.
This is like...
No, no, she's still knocked right there.
North, okay.
Okay.
Wait, what?
No, I'm pretty sure there's three.
No, there was four.
I scanned four people.
Okay, that's then that's different team knock then.
Yeah.
I'll scan again in four.
That's why I was scanning for it.
Okay.
We're in zone.
Yeah, see?
See that?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
That guy.
Look at this.
Meet, meet, meet on the guy in the back.
I'm looking to make sure we're not getting climbed up.
I cracked.
I cracked too.
Yeah.
Oh, I think they killed him.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll try it.
They finally got him.
Yeah, they got him.
Wait, what?
Oh, they're above us.
They're above.
What is that corner?
That is an insane corner.
I think they're gonna drop.
Um, if this team drops, we played, we played behind right
here.
just watch a fucking angle, they are beefing us.
They can't get in.
Throw your, like, thermalising knees as well.
I knocked 1.
Nice.
Alright, I keep fucking Newcastle, Res.
There's people up top there, too.
Watch out for that angle.
They're all up top, on- I'm going to bang up on this zone
close.
I'm going to bang up on this zone close.
Look at this tile.
You hit this, you hit this tile.
Left, west, west, west.
Look at right, I'm looking at right.
Oh, no.
I don't see anything.
I'm banging a thing now.
I'm banging.
there's a team in below us now there's a team right below us
um i guess scanning i'm flying i'm i'm bingo thing i'm bingo
thing i'm bingo thing oh my god wait there's both a huge
fight to our left huge fight to our left smoke the right i i
hit someone for flesh i didn't take anyone i think someone
on the on the hideous i'm gonna i'm gonna look high i'm
gonna look high before they drop i'm looking up right here
maybe they might drop scanning It's no tea.
Just one team below us.
It's just one team.
No one's on height, huh?
Okay.
Yeah, I didn't scan anybody.
I'm not sure if my scan didn't pick it up or anything.
Does anyone have a bat?
I have zero bats.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I dropped two.
I took it.
I'm looking at these guys right now.
I have another scan here.
Yeah, it's just one team below us.
Oh, what?
Six hostiles.
Who the fuck are you?
There's still a team on height.
Yeah, there's still a team on height.
I was like, where the fuck did I get so?
six
Oh, don't have a lot of ammo.
I only have uh, do you guys have extra light or no?
No light.
Okay, I'm gonna run belt now then.
I only have uh 70 bullets.
I think you can play on the height with me One of you.
Uh, I think thai should play height then Let's use it out
Yeah, we have like a little roof here thai Yeah, yeah I'm
watching height Just make sure just so we don't get climbed
up on.
I'm watching watch these like little Wait, wait, wait, look
at this.
Look at this.
Scanning?
There we go.
There's a team up up.
Dropping down.
I'm covering.
I'm dropping.
I dropped.
Oh my god.
I was so scared.
I saw that guy run up to you.
Holy shit.
I'm watching this.
I'm watching this team.
Okay, we have to get out of.
They're running out.
They're like a team on a roof.
There's a team on a roof.
On our roof?
Yeah, I'm fucking scanning.
I'm gonna alt this.
A full team on our roof.
We have to leave soon because of zone.
Oh, that's not going on height.
I'm not going on height.
Okay.
I can scan in two.
Want to hi with you?
Done one hit.
Full night.
Full day.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm looking down.
Right here, there, here.
There's people to our left.
People to our left, too.
I'm looking, looking.
Oh, that bangalers won.
Nice, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, left, left, left, look left, look left.
Wait, we gotta go down to second floor, second floor.
Okay, okay.
I can't go down.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
I'm gonna fly.
I'm gonna, wait, should I fly?
Uh, we got an ape left, ape left, ape left, ape left.
Yeah, I'm gonna land on their heads, okay?
Oh, I got some, I got some, I'm batting, I'm shooting, I'm
shooting, I'm shooting.
I'm gonna land on their heads.
All right, pop a bat, pop a bat, ready?
Ready, ready.
We're gaping, gaping, gaping.
gaping go in
No, no Taya live No
Fucking new castle The new castle we grieved that's okay.
We grieved the new castle team, right?
Yeah, we grieved there.
We got dirt though.
We couldn't really do anything.
We got Bro, that is insane.
You see this guys?
What the fuck?
Look at us Yes!
All odds against us.
Oh, it's them again.
Is it them again?
Bro, just give them the money.
Just give them the money, bro.
Like, let's just, we need like, just like a beer.
Like, we're done.
Let them sit out next game.
They already won.
There's no one fucking catching up.
That is insane.
That was actually a fun round.
Bro, that was crazy.
Look at us.
Yeah, that was fun.
Bro, they have 17 kills.
oh no dude they killed everybody for us oh wait uh can't see
my damage fuck i thought i did a lot you did a thousand i
saw don't worry i got you a thousand thank you apex gods oh
my god 17 kills but we like knocked so many people but they
kept getting res yeah what the was that man we got robbed
yeah we got robbed of our kills mods mods come on give us
those points what's going on here hello yeah scammed should
count us points yeah please apex please it should count that
shit should count oh it's just the last round yeah last game
this isn't fun though bro we could have played so high if I
didn't get blue screen we could I actually feel like, yeah,
I got like a good position too.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and I trust both of them.
We both play over us, so I trust both for FPS skills.
Oh, my God.
That was actually fun.
Yeah, that was a good game.
World's Edge, last game.
Same, I guess, like, same place.
Yep, yep.
Apparently someone said they killed seven teams.
Jesus.
Oh, this guy killed 17.
Dude, he's just a Terminator.
You just never want to see him.
Bro, put him on P20.
They want to be in front of him.
P20 nerf right now.
Yeah, you should only be allowed, dude.
Yeah.
You should only.
You should get the P20 nerf.
No attachments.
He's probably better than me with the P20.
Yeah, you have your fucking PK.
like he gets like yeah
bro you're scared i'm so scared to fight fight team yeah it
might it might be be team 20 it's like you never know right
i want to know what the point gap is i'm actually so curious
i think there's a limit to kill points yeah but they got
like they got three rank they got three first places in uh
three first places though that's true He didn't win the
solo, right?
Who won the solo?
Not UCAB, no.
Who won the solo, yeah?
Who won the solo?
It was...
Oh, Lika.
Lika.
Oh, yeah.
All right, chat, tell us, tell us, like, the first place
team points and then the second place team points.
I'm actually so curious.
I'm so curious how far ahead they are.
That's insane.
that's such a strong lineup
all right we peaked you know it's because of that lockdown
we did yeah yeah we're warmed up yeah yeah wait that's
actually true we locked it in right there we should have
played lockdown in the beginning we should have done that
yeah oh my god we could have been like thirds all the time
okay the next match will not have kill point limit oh he's
gonna fucking go wild yeah he's gonna get like 21 on his own
yeah he's just he they drop off with solos all three go to
go solos yeah they're just different places yeah they all go
to different landsite pois
here we go
oh how much is it yeah
know where the enemy is instead of the next ring?
No, no, there's two.
There's two.
There's a ring console.
There's the ring, and then there's the beacon.
Okay.
Yeah.
So it's like map room scan and ring scan.
We just don't have the character for map room.
Or not map room.
We don't have the character for ring.
So we just But we know where everyone else is going.
So it's pretty much the same thing.
I like how some of my chat is.
Team 20 is first, second, and third.
is 63 points second is 47.
oh no oh my god that's a the gap is not as bad as i thought
we're second right yeah we're we're top 10 no we're 10th
place actually yeah yeah we're actually top 10.
oh yeah yeah top 10 bro hello our goal hey not last yeah not
last bro wait okay but like this last The last game makes or
breaks it, though.
Yeah, we gotta get some KP.
And I feel like everyone just plays normally, yeah.
Landmark is really bad for KP.
Yeah, I mean, we just get shit.
I think we just play normally, no?
Yeah, we just play...
I think we just play how we normally play.
Our fucking Beaconcy has been working well.
Let me in on a place.
Oh, there we go.
We just want a game.
Let us in.
Oh,
we're starting.
Yes.
Same team, comp.
Wait, where are we landing again?
Oh, yeah, middle.
Yeah.
The place.
That place.
Oh, I get Mirage.
I get Mirage.
You guys go land that area.
yeah ping me a carbine and a vault carbine vault yes sir
carbine vault has been working well for me or a repeater
carbine vault carbine repeater vault
let's go all
right here go yeah sick all right okay here yeah little
staging oh i'm gonna land mirage now since oh you're going
oh there's no beacon right i'm yeah yeah okay i shall go all
right i'll land with tayo then let's go let's go i know this
man I trust in our IGF I got you I land the top you can get
the bottom dial I'll grab the top You start Bro, I felt like
we knocked like a billion people.
I know we did everyone just got res'd They're on my life.
I was like, oh my god, we're farming.
Yeah, I was like, oh my god, we got so many kills Nope, it
was like two okay Okay
Let's see, I think I'll go, I'll go repeat it.
Actually, I'll run carbine.
I have a, I have a bolt for you.
I found a bolt just now too.
You can have it if you want that.
I'm good.
Wait, we might have zone guys.
Oh, okay, that is not good.
We have to just loot fast and just set up, I guess.
Wait, yeah, wait, that is actually not good.
gonna get fucking yeah which i i have the key thing too if
we need and blue backpack uh let me know when to scan
because i feel like uh i don't know i don't know if i should
scan early but like i'm worried that i'm gonna get fucking
run up on uh when we're about to leave probably to scan oh
first kill revenant this is running oh rev oh god it started
oh people are people are going for kills wait can i can i
loot this yeah cool i'm gonna get that blue backpack then
i'm gonna grab the our little the lava fisher team is
ballooning right now they have a big get anything they
balloon to us let's see where they're going uh i don't see
where they're going yet uh they are heading towards probably
thermal choke yeah they are heading towards yeah if they're
heading towards thermal go go up this choke or that height
right here where we okay you want me a scan or no wait
there's a there's no balloon there's no balloon yeah yeah
scan the beacon wait wait they did it there there there
there i think it is so here they're on me wait i'm coming
they're over here they're over here they're over here they
haven't crossed it they haven't crossed yet yeah i think i
think they're just rotating okay i'll get us blur i'm coming
to you guys too it's okay yeah they're just going towards
thermal we can go for the beacon scan i'll watch oh they're
out they're out there they left yeah they left attack 140.
that's scary holy shit where are we going the oh i'm gonna
scan the beacon real quick top of the hill
Scanning?
Wait, scan this...
Oh, what is this drop?
What is this drop?
I'm kind of...
Yeah, everyone's going to Thermo.
Wait, I think we should...
Let's go for this drop.
I have the key on me if we need to use the key.
I need a scope, if you guys find one.
I have a...
Go play for this drop.
I'm gonna get our weapon supply.
Okay.
I'm waiting for the drop right now.
I'm not risking that, Ash.
I feel like somebody's I feel like they're gonna grab it
first before us Oh, we're good We're chilling There is
thermal they're resting there they're resting at um, um,
whatever it's called Whatever that english lava fishery
Volcano shit Is it r e oh gold r e not bad I'm just gonna
get it.
It's not bad.
Do you want to use it?
I can't.
I'll drop my vault.
Anyone wants to have a purple in here.
Nah, I'm just gonna shotgun.
Alright, I'm gonna run double light.
Alright, we're just gonna hold here.
We hold here and we always...
We just hold our mirage side.
Alright.
Oh, finally a scope.
Okay, this is gonna be the most...
I'm gonna drop the key because I don't think we're gonna
grab it anyway.
We need to...
like we only need to fight once here once or twice like that
once we win those one like those ones or twice two fights we
have a okay i'll look in front of us then why you guys i i
just i'm just looking yeah yeah i'll look in the front then
there's watson team in the house there's a medkit here but
that's probably cheeky and them again bro no farming
everybody They're just running it down.
Yeah, too bad.
It's the 20.
They don't even need to play the game.
There's a team.
There's a Loba team in this house.
And so, uh, East.
I know.
There's a Loba lifeline team.
They're just, they're just, don't care about the KP.
Yeah, they, they were placement, man.
Lifeline drop.
All right.
You gotta let me know who's cracked because I have my pew,
pew, pew, my hammer point.
Okay, I'm just smoking out.
Try to make my presence known.
trees yeah that's fine okay okay i don't know the drop up
but it's fine that was a single fire god damn it yeah is
that rampart too single fire that shit oh yeah it's rampart
wait no it's rampart caustic loba yeah the lifeline then i
was like wait a minute that's a rampart i don't waste my
light you guys on board Do anything.
Taya, we gotta keep top 10.
We gotta- Turn off your DPS brain.
We got an honorable ending here.
Turn off your DPS brain.
Okay, you're serious.
It should be a party there, by the way.
They're a resident at Lava Fission.
Yeah.
And before, it's like fucking Harvester again.
Oh, yes, we got Zone.
Nice.
Yes.
should i shouldn't push up past this yeah no no oh people oh
my god i'm gonna scan for you like really far off yeah look
behind here back they're far and back to do they're probably
gonna just chill there until like next they might they might
ape watch out i'm looking across i'm looking across for you
i'm watching yeah i don't think anybody's gonna they're
gonna wait there until next zone
this or are we going i'll scan this someone signal at all
they back although oh that's a valve that was them i'll see
oh they fucked up no it's blue purples they're over there
i'm about i'm gonna get angles here yeah they're not sure
i'm gonna look behind so we need to look behind still
they're on top of the roof let me push here though i'm
looking behind they're like below you they're below you
urese they're like on this rock they're not getting shot
from behind oh no no no whoa whoa i got sniped behind no no
no here no no no i got sniped behind us yeah i only have two
they're like right there i have a bunch of themselves i'll
give you yeah i have three bats though do you need bats here
we go yeah i need one bat please shoot them yes why are you
shooting us all right am i oh my god i'll look also look
behind us i'll stay here then so i won't get shot a team
that's that that fucking team is not shooting them yeah
they're in the house why aren't they shooting them they're
scared yeah they're scared they need the placements i'm
about to shoot at the house i'm about to shoot at the Yeah,
we like guys.
Yeah, look at, look at, look over here.
Oh, fuck.
I swear if you shoot them and they look at me, I swear to
God.
That should, that should do it, right?
Oh, you're using some brain stress here.
I don't see anybody yet.
I don't have any fucking ammo.
I just need like a safe spot.
Yeah, looks like it.
Right there.
Oh, team, team, team, team.
They landed to our left.
Okay, okay.
Come back, come back, come back.
I see that.
They're on the height right now, here on the rock.
They smoked?
They're smoking us.
I didn't get anybody my scan.
Not pushing it.
If we fight this, we can't get knocked, since we're just
going to get pushed by this team as well.
We kind of have to fight from like a little more upfront so
we don't get...
Looks like they're rotating.
They're getting shot from other people.
I can scan the three.
Oh, they're on top of the thing.
They drop.
Yeah, there's two teams there.
That should be good.
They start fighting.
Someone needs to watch that.
I'm going to watch the people on hers.
Yeah, I'll watch.
I'll watch.
Playing the bus right now.
I'm still watching for us.
Yeah.
I see him.
He's like, they ran to our left.
He's behind that rock.
The team's behind that rock.
I'm watching them.
He's still down again.
It's a Pathfinder bang team.
They're still there.
Chris.
Yep.
Oh, whoa.
Okay, I'm batting.
I expected them to shoot.
35 purple.
Crack the bang.
Oh, they're a purple armor now, the people under here.
No one in this.
I only have one bat, so I'm not going to poke too much.
How many cells do you have?
Okay, okay.
I have a lot of cells.
I'm good.
This team shouldn't go for us.
Like, they should just, like, stay on their side, this team.
We're going to play for a Valholt here.
Okay.
A good Valholt probably to be landing, like, underneath
here.
that platform okay where should we about we can we can just
look uh we can just move up from like over here looks like
they're pushing us look oh scanning i'm watching don't give
him entry all right i'm just gonna alt for now i can give
you all the cells yeah i have all the cell i'm fine i think
they're gonna push i think they're just making i think
they're also just making sure we don't push them maybe or
maybe the valk the bloodhound all scared them they came up
to Yeah.
He ran back.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Wait for Valkald.
We're gonna Valkald from here.
Over here?
I think that's the Bloodhound.
The Bloodhound.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got one.
It's fine.
I took another.
I have one as well.
All right.
I'll just do it again so we can have it for...
Yeah.
The next fight.
17 seconds.
Come to my side.
Yes, sir.
We're just gonna baffle from here as well.
Here?
Right here's fine.
Do we have cover here?
Yeah, I'm just worried about- Yep, yep, yep.
Here?
Do we do it?
Team shouldn't push us.
Alright, ready?
Yep.
3, 2, 1.
Rip it.
I'm just gonna spam Spingy, where are we landing?
Just move towards like over here.
No one's underneath, let's go.
Take underneath, can take underneath.
Underneath the platform.
form.
I'm on her.
Oh, it's chill right here.
All right, we're just chilling right here.
Watch her, watch her landings as well.
Try to scan and make presents now.
We're over here.
Just show, just show presents.
Just show presents.
Okay.
I got one.
Yeah, on top of the building.
There's a caustic.
How many, how many do you have?
How many teams is that?
Uh, 1.16.
There's so many teams.
Okay, yeah.
by the way oh okay i got one kill i'm gonna look forward
keep watching our back yeah i'm watching up here i'm
watching up here don't we get shot though from here no
actually i should be fine yeah there's a team right here i'm
scanning okay that's the team that i killed i think the
people in the house yeah like the i uh i pop my old pop
that's old itself hi yeah okay right here right here i'm 40
i get my gold helmet too
i might need to vattle for this like a squad here since
there's a team in front of us armor in the house like can't
really fight this properly 83 just gonna get shot in the
back hostile oh wait they rest okay
90 we we we're gonna play for this like just walk it in walk
it in make sure this team behind us like don't push us i'm
looking at them they they've been in the house so far in
this house yeah there's people on the first floor right here
i vote i vote iris i'll give back your helmet yeah there's
like a team there's a team i'm not for it in the choke from
there the choke team yeah like tell me what to fight
fighting on the height there's fight they're just fighting
here on the height they're just he might drop into us maybe
holy what the fall whoa what's going on i got one i got one
holy shit yeah this team is watching us buckled right now
buckled right now yeah yeah yeah we're gonna look for like a
third party or yeah we're gonna look for a third party just
fly around fly around just find a circle maybe just like fly
around yeah fly in circles thing Jesus Christ.
Land right here, land right here, land right here, land
right here, land right here on the height.
I didn't fucking make it.
I'm ulting them, I'm ulting the same.
I'm ulting the same.
I make it to the height too.
The bloodhound, pushing left, pushing left.
I'm scanning.
I'm hugging this wall.
Yeah, I'm hugging this wall.
Push this bloodhound, push this bloodhound, push this
bloodhound.
I'm ulting, I'm ulting.
I got hit by that.
Fuck, okay.
Crack, crack, crack, crack.
Wait, I can't, I don't have a bat.
I'm selling, I'm selling.
Oh, dude, what of these?
One HP.
right there right there in front of you oh i didn't see that
guy no no 13th bro how many people were there there's too
many people bro i thought they were getting shot in the back
of course it's fucking cheeky and then wait who's the
bloodhound cheeky is cheeky the blood no i literally like
clipped him with my Fingerma jig the the have the the head
log.
Yeah, yeah He was like he was like probably like half meat
and then he just turned around and just one bagged me
We could have landed anybody it had to be cheeky Yeah, it
had to be I thought they were getting shot in the back like
when we were like flying They looked like they were getting
shot in the back.
And I almost killed their bang too their fight when we
landed maybe I'm pretty sure oh my god the team didn't like
push them yeah oh my god of all people there was like 17
teams there we picked the fucking the first the worst
possible our our gotcha luck is terrible guys I'm just gonna
watch cheeky shit what the fuck bro I'm just gonna watch
Yeah, bro.
What?
What is he?
He has no recoil.
Bro, it's cheap.
And then he has no recoil.
He actually has no recoil.
This shit is insane.
Bro, rank hard in him so hard.
Dude, he's literally getting ammo.
Like...
He's getting fed.
Yeah, he's like, oh, what the fuck?
Bro, what the...
Wait.
What's the difference of this?
Dude, he's so good.
He's so good.
What's the difference?
Bro, of course he's on Bloodhound.
The roller player is always on Bloodhound.
Bro, there's no, I can't compare to that.
This dude literally just won 80s and just headshots me five
times in a row.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, nothing.
You just roll over and die.
You show your stomach and you're like, Oh, shit.
What is this dude?
Dude, he's running out.
He's an ape.
I don't know.
What is this?
What an ape.
This is an ape.
Oh, is he going to win?
Are they going to win again?
Bro, I think they're going to win again.
He is old.
No way.
Yeah, they will.
They win again.
Oh my god, the fucking gibby bubble saved their life.
Holy fuck.
He can't miss.
Oh, he can't miss.
Mom.
He won't miss.
What?
What is this?
That's not fair.
No.
What is this?
I wish, I wish Valk ult, they tell you where you, they tell
you which team you're landing on.
Yeah.
If we knew, if I knew it was cheeky, I would not have landed
there.
I would fucking laugh time.
It's not fair, man.
Fourth, first place is in a row.
Bro.
No, they, they've won every single one.
won right they won every single yeah trios every trios
they've won bro check his pc check his controller yeah dude
his controller is like taking some bro what controller does
he use let me buy it what place for me 13th with one kill oh
that's not bad we got we got points bro fucking 13 kills we
guys are the team that won so yeah yeah we definitely that
doesn't count we're like second place yeah it doesn't count
we we landed on the only team we were the only team to
contest them we were the only team that stood up and we're
like no no i think we are going to 1v1 you guys i'm pretty
sure the other teams just fucking also try to kill them and
die oh my god that team was insane bro check his computer
man that's fun though I had a great time what do you guys I
had an amazing time bro we should play Overwatch together
you should Tyo should carry it it's Tyo's turn to carry it
wait you should be on the Overwatch now Yeah, yeah, time
next time play you guys got carry Get your revenge get your
revenge on fucking overwatch.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Help your use get to diamond Can we get cheeky in here?
You get cheeky into the team Wouldn't be one yeah wouldn't
be one be one tile
There's no aim assist there Everybody's like Immortal 3 in
Valaran too.
Bro, he's Immortal 3 Yeah, he's actually real.
He's actually good in Valaran as well.
Bro, wait, likeoh my god, he might win the 1v1, Taya.
He might be better than you in Overwatch.
Uh, probably not.
I think I'm fine.
Don't worry about that.
Like, GGs, let's see whatyou always want to know what
placement we got?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's see what placement we got.
Isn't there like a mainstream?
should be it should be where's the scars mainstream i'm
pretty sure they're like doing an interview right now or
something with cheeky yeah cheeky the fucking yeah the
immortal god in the four first places i'm pretty sure he is
the god of apex if anyone no no that's i mean maybe he's a
in japan he's the ceo yeah exactly we have hal and then
apparently there's like a random like a random hat winner oh
yeah yeah they pull a they pull like a piece of paper to see
who gets it and then um yeah yeah yeah so like we could
maybe you know we don't have luck here but we have luck in
the gotcha that is true that's true it's all about the
gotcha i'm i'm getting off though once we that are
leaderboard i'm sick right now oh you okay from challenge uh
from yesterday bro i didn't sleep until like 6 a.m bro what
you came in here with no sleep this man was out partying oh
that's where it gets us in the beginning yeah i'm sorry i'm
sorry it's okay you know we got third place even with every
with all the debuffs in that last game True.
With all that debuffs, we still got third in that last game.
That's all that matters.
Oh, they're still- wait, oh, they're still- oh no, they're
looking at highlights.
Yeah, this dude just kills three people.
He just kills like, he just kills four people in a row, you
know?
Just cheeky fools.
This is a normal Tuesday.
Yeah, just normal cheeky days.
That's like a little Ryan game.
Yeah, this man plays rank even when there's hackers every
day.
Yeah, because he's stronger than them.
He's stronger than the hackers.
He's just better.
At least we know we're not last.
That's all that matters.
Not last.
Let's go.
Not last equals win.
Placements don't matter.
It's only first and last place.
And we were at last.
Technically we can be second.
What is the mainstream?
Oh, we're in 14th place.
We're in 14th.
look almost not last that's all we're better than yeah look
at all these other people were better than it's all right
nice wait we're like we're not that far from like top you
know yeah top 10 we literally needed five yeah we literally
needed like if we got like the kill points from that other
game i think we would be like yeah yeah if if we didn't land
on on cheeky's team we could have been top 10 we could have
been it could have been there's there like three people that
have 24 points holy fuck oh my god hey you got your estimate
right you're easy you're like you know what i mean 14 to 15
plays you get right you read what a smart ass can i say man
what can i say man you read us perfectly oh my we did it
guys thank you guys That was- I enjoyed that a lot.
Yeah, you did too.
I had so much fun.
It was fucking fun.
Next time...
Next time Tio carries us in Overwatch.
Yeah, yeah.
Next time it's Overwatch, he might carry you guys.
Boost your yeast to...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
We're Mercy, pocket.
We're Mercy.
We're Mercy, you know?
Damage boost.
That's what I'm saying.
Damage boost, Tim, as Mercy.
Tio on Mercy.
Your support's like gold, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you just play Mercy and damage boost your ease.
Yeah, boost him.
Yeah, yeah.
Damage boost.
By damage boost.
For legal reasons, I meant damage boost.
Not anything else.
Not anything.
I don't even know anything else but damage boost.
Yeah, exactly.
You don't need heals.
A true Mercy player knows it's all about damage boosting.
Yeah.
But he doesn't need heals if he kills everybody.
He has, yeah, they have regen now.
Overwatch players can eat regen.
Yeah, like, you don't even need heals.
Yeah, you don't even have...
Wait, was that not a thing before?
No, yeah, no, it was only...
Like, before then, there was no regen.
There was only support players.
Yeah, and then they added support, and then they're like,
everybody gets regen.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, so don't worry.
You don't need heals.
You just wait for your regen.
all right GGs guys that was fun you guys get some rest yeah
get some rest Yuri's get feel better thank you thank you
nice meeting both of you GGs bye bye I had a great time that
was my first time like interacting with Yuri's entire game
that was so fun we were so close to time 10 we were
literally literally top 10 was three points away it was so
crazy everyone was so fucking congested together if i didn't
get the blue screen it was the blue screen i still can't
believe i got the blue screen that's so fucked up also tommy
i want to say thank you for the akaka super i'm sorry i
didn't wasn't able to read it read super chats while
streaming but thank you again Tommy oh not when I'm stream
when I'm doing collab doing doing collab um sometimes I
won't say I'm not able to read super chats but thank you so
much 6 30 a.m on Friday we feeling generous enjoy your beans
get some some good food or something thank you again for the
aca-aca-supa I can't believe it we were so close we could
have actually got top 10 if I did a blue screen the curse I
got cursed by tile I actually got cursed by tile It's like
crazy, man.
Um, um, but yeah, anyway, it was incredibly fun playing with
them.
I had a great time.
Um, that were my first JP tournament back here as Doki.
And, um, it was, I'm really happy that they invited me.
And I'm really happy that, uh, it was fun just messing
around, just, uh, talking.
Oh my god, Challenger Circuit is Tomato!
By the way, Wake Tempo and I, we have not fucking practiced
at all as a team because everybody's busy.
I gave them my schedule too.
I was like, all right, here's my schedule.
Just as long as I can do it before my streams, that's really
good.
And they're like, cool.
And then we're supposed to practice today, like today, on my
rest day.
And then, or like on my rest day.
Yeah.
And then the thing is, the thing.
was um we don't know what happened to wig he disappeared he
actually we don't know what happened to him he like never
showed up we're like where where's wig i was like we're like
i'm ready i just woke up i'm ready to play where's wig and
then he never we don't know what happened to him and then we
had like somebody like text him because they had their phone
number so they're like hey where are you Like, and then
like, Tempo was like, yeah, he had like three hours of
sleep, so I think he's fucking out, and I'm like, what?
I was like, bro!
Like, bro, because at first we were supposed to play the day
before, the day before yesterday, but then Wig was like, I
can't make it, can we do that?
Can we do, like, Thursday?
I was like, yeah, sure, we can do Thursday.
Did they even ever showed up?
Bro, what happened?
Guys, I don't know.
I think we're out in round one, which I'm fine with.
Honestly, it's all right if we're out after.
Honestly, I'm totally fine if we're out after round one.
I tried.
I woke up.
I actually woke up, guys.
So, I don't know what the fuck is going on, but, like, we'll
see.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to call it here.
Thank you, everybody, for coming to the stream.
I hope you guys all had amazing, fun times with your recent
tile.
I'm totally down to play Overwatch with them.
It'll be really fun.
But, yes, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture
check, get them and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
you